[Laughter]
hey you guys it's friday happy friday
everybody
we're gonna uh
go out later tonight so yeah we're gonna
do a show probably about two hours yeah
we'll hang out with you guys for a
couple hours beforehand have a couple
drinks right then we'll have some dinner
real quick and then yeah we're gonna
kind of head out because um
we're gonna pre-game a little bit but uh
we only have enough alcohol between the
two of us to
not get as [ __ ] up
yeah gonna go to mannequins they're
doing uh theme tonight is witches ball
yeah they're waiting on us
so yeah but like i said that's still a
couple hours away and i already mostly
got ready it's just i gotta change out
the is there a thing are you doing a
witch thing are you just going no i'm
just going like that i'm just going i
don't know i don't i don't have a witch
thing yeah i was thinking about doing
green hair but then i was like i don't
know i have a green wig but i don't like
it as much as this one all right
that's all i'm going to do with that
yeah just trying to get the ball rolling
see what you guys are doing it's friday
imagine some of you guys are pre-gaming
too if not you're just going to stay in
i mean it is only 6 p.m it's only six
months
well it's 6 p.m here yeah in other parts
of the world it's all different other
kinds of times really i wouldn't i
didn't know that it's just yeah we're on
global time okay
so some of y'all might be getting ready
it's actually it's probably it's early
in the rest of the united states isn't
it yeah uh no
yeah yeah it's earlier yeah it's earlier
so it's probably about three
zack says well i'm pretty certain i have
covered oh [ __ ]
i hope not i ain't worried about it but
well of course you're not worried about
it it's not you is it
[Laughter]
tom doesn't worry about anything that's
not him i looked at who died it was old
people
dj maniac also said i watched the acid
king on 2b last night documentary about
the ricky casto satanic panic murder i
remember that [ __ ] that was all over the
[ __ ]
talk shows back in the old days
uh half man maybe 20 minutes from where
i live i should probably watch that
actually because
yeah i might have seen it i don't
remember but because i did see a
documentary about that particular case i
might have watched it before we did the
satanic panic show
danny rowling says a show about famous
medieval executioners and their methods
of execution would be cool to hear about
just saying
that actually is a good idea for you we
could talk about we could do like a
medieval torture episode yeah that'd be
a good one i mean well give me my pen
and i forgot to bring my pen and paper
over here so i can like write down some
suggestions for stuff
okay so i'm gonna write that down just
whatever check it over there
we're gonna put let's see medieval
torture
is it yeah okay there we go medieval
torture
um let's
see camp guy says peacocks make a lot of
noise yeah they do they um peacocks
actually sounds like a woman screaming
like when they make a noise
i think
it kind of sounds or it sounds like a
person screaming yeah hugo said it's 3
p.m here in l.a
is is international donut day
is it all right oh my god
yeah
hi david what's up are you going to
mannequins tonight because we're going
yeah we'll be there we're just getting
ready like you know we're we're gearing
up
[Laughter]
getting ready getting ready
i mean i kind of feel like because
aren't they changing up the i think
they're changing up the thing saturday a
little bit like to make it more like
friday
um
and they kind of wanted a lot of people
to come saturday too because they you
know they want to show that that's
viable instead of just like people
having walk-ins and stuff no i don't i
didn't know i thought it was your way
around okay no i told you that the other
day okay friday's gonna be a little bit
more like old saturday
no that's not that's not what i said not
she said i think friday and saturday the
same now yeah similar okay similar well
saturday's gonna be more like
visage used to be which is kind of like
old post-punk 80s that's kind of what it
feels like though
well not really because i mean it
started out like that but then it
started going into like other kind of
music you know what i mean because
remember last time we went on saturday
it was well they start places and
whatever they start playing that's what
i'm saying they kind of wanted to like
not do that as much
so
they're just they're doing yeah yeah
dave said yeah he's gone
the wife has even cooked me up sloppy
joe's
[Laughter]
flappy chest yeah saturday's massage
reunion nights that's what i thought
like cause tina told me to like make the
uh the poster for that and i was like
that's a good idea probably because i
mean we've been
we went on one saturday it was like
super fun and it was like every single
song was good but then like the last
time we went on saturday it was there
was good music early but then it started
getting kind of like
you know shittier and shittier like as
the night went on like in all is all the
randos like wandered in well he was
playing to them that's what i was saying
which that's what i would have done on
that particular night you're trying to
get you're trying to get customers and
they were paid
you know i mean if they played just to
us
yeah you're not you're not making you're
not expanding the market you know
you paid them damn normies and they they
they probably made a couple grand at the
bar right there just in a few hours
so yeah sure they did got to keep the
[ __ ] bar running
we got our own knights and that [ __ ]
passes they're not in there long it's
like a pub crawl
they come in that's the that's the good
thing is that at least they don't hang
out in there yeah
they come in
they hang out for like two or three
songs and the [ __ ] bar makes money
then they split and it goes back to
normal david understands what i'm
talking about
slasher fred says one of these days you
should review either the wraith or the
crow i'm pretty sure we already did the
crow we did yeah we did i think we did
yeah i'm pretty sure we did the grow we
haven't done the wraith though yeah i'll
have to write that down because i think
that's one that i was like looking at
like to put in the patreon poll but i
don't think we got around to it because
i think i saw it on
2b or some [ __ ] like that crow was good
in its time
yeah i mean it's very 90s but i mean
there's nothing wrong with that it
pretty much held up got a great
soundtrack
it does yeah um it held up
it's just uh it looks very dated you
know i mean there was but there is
practical it's all practical effects but
um you know
kind of slow by today's standards
it's kind of slow how about that i mean
it's kind of slow i guess
well i have to go and see it maybe
you're just getting maybe you're just
developing adhd in your own age
i'd have to go back and see all that out
there
last time i saw it i was like you know
there isn't a whole lot to this
but you know we'll see
dave said uh it was random for the
muggles yeah last saturday it was
alternative all night
okay so yeah i thought that they were
trying it out for
for this month like to see
to see how it was
i mean i like and honestly i kind of
like it's harder for us to go out friday
nights i don't mind going out friday
nights it's just harder because we do
the show first so it's i always have to
like coordinate it's like should i get
ready before
this before we live stream and then just
kind of like rush or should i not and
then we have to rush like after the
show's over and it's like all this other
kind of like
kind of crap and then i can't drink too
much on the live stream because then you
know i can't drink when i get there and
i don't remember seeing david at momento
yeah i don't think yeah
yeah i don't think he'd well normally i
think he just hangs out at mannequins
right i mean yeah because they had
memento at the new barbarella and that
was actually like really good like a
bunch of people came yeah a bunch of
people came yeah so i didn't mix drinks
but
that's okay though well like i said i
wasn't really planning on getting all
that [ __ ] up that night anyway not
like i ever planned it's cans but they
don't care if you they don't care if you
go out to their car and [ __ ] slam if
they're out in the parking lot [ __ ]
drinking and they come yeah i mean if i
hadn't known that probably we would have
brought our own but because most people
did it seemed like but it's in the
warehouse district so it's got big
[ __ ] parking right there there's
nobody and no one's around there's no
walk-ins it's as private as [ __ ]
i really like which means you could just
you could dress any way you wanted you
know these girls could go in there half
nude like they do some time for them no
one's gonna and no one's gonna like
bother them yeah which is nice but um my
uh my recommendation when when it comes
to buying anything out of the bar if you
don't like beer which
i only like beer if it's like you know
mixed with [ __ ] cider you know like
stout and cider uh you know it was a
black velvet i like that but it's so
fattening though man
but the only thing that was i would
recommend out of the can was that
bacardi um
mojito it was pretty good it was weird
it was good well yeah i think they're
only what five ten percent alcohol yeah
those kind of mixed yeah and they
weren't cheap like seven bucks uh and
you had to watch it because i could
drink a [ __ ] i could drink a case of
those and get only halfway [ __ ]
sauced but they were you know
out of what they were offering that was
the best one
i kind of wish that they had had thank
you next dimension media have a shot on
me tonight well thank you
thank you very much
i didn't notice like they had a bunch of
stuff in there and i had like i tried a
bunch of different things i had a couple
of beers and then i had um
one that was like a vodka with like lime
and cucumber that was all right
it was kind of gross at first but it
kind of grew on me
and i had one that was a gin and tonic
that was tanqueray and that was good but
it was like real tart so i could really
only have one because i said i'm gonna
get heartburn if i keep drinking these
um they didn't i didn't notice if they
had uh bloody mary though because well
how good would that be like a bloody
mary in a cage
i could slam that [ __ ] i haven't had a
bloody mary in a long time yeah out of
what they were offering i'd recommend
like i said that mojito was good they
had two different kinds i had the
bacardi one she said the other one was
good too but i didn't have it
they had a pina colada too actually i
was gonna i was gonna try that out but
then i was just kind of like i didn't
really want to drink anymore because
that didn't taste right to me unless
it's frozen
yeah that's true dave says i work at
webster monday morning i wake up at 3 30
a.m so sundays is a no-go yeah that's
understandable and he said i really
wanted to go to yeah it was really fun
it was good
that's a good place i like that it's i
mean it's it was weird because it's not
anything like their old location
but
i like the location that it's at now
it's almost kind of like back in the old
days it's [ __ ] huge they have to
[ __ ] um wall it off into a smaller
area so it's this you know so it's kind
of club-like
it looks like the way it was decorated
it's the size of a warehouse but
it looks like the way it was decorated
it was a uh some kind of fitness center
it was a sports center first uh
badminton okay is that the west coast it
was a badminton
all that stuff's gone is but it's you
know it's carpeted floors and it's just
it's all blue and black on the inside
and
the wall and the ceilings are super high
like you know 50 40 50 foot ceiling i
mean it's three stories of ceilings
easily
big
um
it's just the way it is
okay it's all you know just kind of
weird
it didn't the lights aren't really
[ __ ] that good yet but they said
they're gonna work on it and they'll he
has a liquor license just that he has to
build all the stuff to get the uh
the uh to get it to code so he could use
his uh yeah license
but like i said that's not really a deal
breaker for me honestly it's just kind
of like look if i go a place and well
because remember for a long time we used
to go to shows at will's pub and they
didn't have a liquor license for a long
time yeah so i was just like oh well
i'll just get beer or you know i would
get like they had like coffee stout or
something like that i would get that
so i'm not really all that bothered as
long as i as long as i get some [ __ ]
i'll just drink soda i don't care it'd
be a great place just for special
offense you know raves goth stuff fetish
stuff stuff where you kind of want you
don't want the public around that's
that's what that'd be a good place for
you yeah because like i said you have to
go there on purpose it's not like people
are going to be wandering down the
street it's not an area that people walk
around yeah it's in the middle of a
bunch of warehouses yeah i mean and
there's nothing really close by that's
open even
so yeah i like that about it because i
you know and honestly like where they
used to be right in the middle of
downtown
um it was pretty good like yeah you got
obnoxious randos like coming in there
but it wasn't as bad as you might think
it was considering how much
foot traffic there was but that's
because there was a bunch of other clubs
along that street too yeah and i
borrowed barbarella what do you want to
call it had been there for a [ __ ] 40
years and everybody knew that
was what it was so that's that that's
that kind of club right you know what i
mean it's not it's not a goth club it
was more like
it's like an 80s alternative
that type of stuff yeah everything i
mean they played different stuff on
different nights they had some indie
stuff and things like that but everybody
knew that that was the bar for that yeah
it was all the bar for the weirdos yeah
that was like the weirdest part like
whatever flavor of weirdo you were
it was it was very like welcoming but um
yeah so there were like some other bars
along with other kinds of music so like
if you were into that so you didn't
really get too many people just like
wandering in
because everybody that was from here
like well they went in there because
they wanted to see it
yeah i mean it's not like they were just
looking what is this place no they they
knew yeah
greenspark says happy friday all jenny
look gorgeous this evening thank you
thank you yeah i got i i got five
percent more pretty because i'm going
out later
less ugly i don't i guess it could be
the same thing
it's technically the same thing yeah
um cam guy said he made some fried green
tomatoes sound good i haven't had five
great fried greens gardens yielding all
kinds of tomatoes but when it yields it
yields them all at once
so i had to turn them into [ __ ]
tomato sauce but it's good tomato sauce
i forgot what tomato sauce made out of
real tomatoes it looks like it's orange
it's not red tomatoes from the garden
tastes like so much better yeah there's
not at the store yeah they don't taste
like vegetables it tastes like fruit
they taste so
they taste so much like a uh almost like
a strawberry yeah they're they're sweet
real they're just real good
i mean the thing about it too and i
think i mentioned this on the last side
tracks is that we got so many
eggplant yeah already i got a bunch of
those coming holy crap yeah i didn't
realize that they would grow that fast
and you know those those sugar pumpkins
that i that i grew yeah you don't have
to peel them i just baked them and i
pureed the entire thing peel and all
it's and it just the peel disappears
because it's so sweet yeah and then i
read i read later they said yeah eat the
peel so i said i called it right because
the skin is so thin on them they're not
big though
they're they're they're only that big
what you're going to do with them you
know i just got a puree bread or pumpkin
pie or something or you could i could
spice them and then turn them into you
know like a
like a mashed potato type side you know
oh yeah because it just tastes like
sweet potato but probably uh or you
could do like we made a pumpkin curry
before didn't we do pumpkin cream yeah i
think i'll make bread out of it though
yeah i do like pumpkin bread that's
especially good that's especially good
for breakfast like yeah i got all that i
got all that flour which i probably make
pumpkin bread but
i'm gonna plant some of the bigger
pumpkins they take longer
but the yield i think is better
because when it's done
i gotta check to see what's a good time
to plant it
because when it's done it remember how
we had we for that one halloween we
bought
three
pumpkins on discount because the season
because halloween was over remember that
well it was just i think it was just two
pumpkins i think it was just two
and
i baked that
and pureed it
and put it in that damn
big ass five gallon
container and put it in the back
refrigerator
and we ate off of that for three months
yeah a long time a long time so much
[ __ ] with that stuff
so that means that you know
[ __ ]
10 of those things is a year's worth of
it
and you can and you can freeze it yeah
yeah and freeze it yeah that's what i
thought yeah 10 would be like a year's
worth of it that's if you were eating
pumpkin pie
curry
um and bread you couldn't live off of it
it's just supplementary you know what i
mean but there's not a lot of nutrition
there but it's it's a component into
making stuff you know
pretty good
if you had to you know if the world was
ending in [ __ ] you could just eat it
like you could sweet potatoes
i love pumpkin yeah it's good you can
put it in everything as well yeah makes
a great soup or stew or a curry that's
another thing we could do with pumpkin
soup i love pumpkin soup yeah
delicious pour it into a glass and just
drink it out of a mug pour it into a mug
we did that a couple thanksgivings ago
that was that was kind of like while the
turkey was cooking and everything like
that we just had pumpkin soup and like
coconuts and stuff yeah i don't remember
appetizers i think i just used uh
cinnamon i think i just used pumpkin pie
spice wasn't it
as far as like yeah
turmeric yeah it had turmeric in it yeah
you got to put turmeric in turmeric in
there yeah turmeric and i think pumpkin
pie type spices it was [ __ ] really
good
tammy said she made a peach cobbler this
morning and used tom's recipe out of the
book yes
yes it was good wasn't it
we made a couple well you made a couple
cobblers like recently he made a peach
cobbler and he made a couple berry cups
yeah i got those frozen berries i'm
going to go uh
thaw those things and and cook them into
a syrup and then use
i'm making big sheet pans of it
the
uh the recipe i probably gave you is for
a small one i double or triple that up
okay
uh to make a big thick one in a bigger
pan
and even melt a whole stick of butter in
the bottom of it so it doesn't stick
roll it around [ __ ] pour the [ __ ] in
there and this is why i have so much
trouble using losing weight yeah i know
that's the thing i got jenny on a diet
you got bee on a diet
i got me on a diet yes so uh
and i see i'm really bad
at
portion control yeah you are
i i can eat large portions because my
metabolism runs so hard because of
[ __ ] all the supplements i'm on i can
eat anything and still [ __ ] just yeah
but you could you were like that before
you know before you went on all that and
i kept trying to tell you it's like look
my metabolism is like
molasses slow and honestly i feel better
when i don't eat that much at once if i
eat like a big portion at once i feel
kind of ill
afterward even though i might want to
like even though i might be hungry but
i'm always kind of afterward i'm always
like why did i do that like i always
feel like really crappy
um i always feel better when i it's like
i have to eat but i feel better when i
eat like smaller
like just a couple small portions of
something like that i was resistant to
getting fat up until i hit about 45. i
think that's true pretty much everybody
yeah and then you get it
really lucky it starts going damn i
can't get away with what i used to get
away with
and then you know about time i was 15
started working out and getting back in
the gym trying to lose that [ __ ] gut
lose that [ __ ] body fat i had good
results but going on hrt [ __ ] super
helped and then
some of that other [ __ ] that i get on it
[ __ ] that that's good to me i went on
cycle today too
i went on cycle i'm going on today it's
gonna be a mild [ __ ] rebuild
maintenance cycle
but
it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna be good
i've been [ __ ] doing work on a core
trying to get the [ __ ] waist down
slimmer and [ __ ] the six-pack it's
coming
ian england says baked pumpkin seeds are
good as well yeah they are we've done um
i think last year or the year before
when we had those halloween pumpkins
that we baked we
we roasted all the seeds like with maple
syrup i think like we can we candied
them yeah i can't eat them that that
works but they were a little too hard
they were a little too woody
and what i did what i did was i did some
research on it
and and
[ __ ] complained about that in my
search
and came up with a new recipe
boil them before you do go through that
oh yeah okay that would probably soften
them up boil them to soften my softener
i mean they were so good but yeah and
then let them dry
and then cover them and put them on a
sheet pad and cover them in um
a maple syrup and you can sprinkle any
kind of seasoning you want on there
would be it you know cinnamon or
whatever a nutmeg give them a couple
little tosses in that a little bit of
that syrup
it'll make a it'll make kind of like a
sticky paste kind of like a real sticky
oatmeal and then
push them out over a non-stick pan and
bake them
and then bust them all up if they if
they're not separated like almost like a
little bit of a peanut brittle not that
not a bad peanut brittle but
and then eat them that way and it should
be a lot better man having a peanut
butter in a long time either yeah easy
to make yeah i mean sugar butter i made
it in uh junior high actually
really bad for you it is yeah but it's
delicious it's delicious yeah yeah yeah
i mean it's one of those things that
like it's like a one eight once a year
treat or something like that like around
the holidays or some [ __ ] just like
peppermint bark and stuff like that like
i love that kind of [ __ ] but i don't eat
it every day like i just do like peanut
butter fudge
oh my god my mom used to make that right
now and then when i was a kid she made
the best [ __ ] pizza and the best
peanut butter cookies too i like fudge
too but there's something about peanut
butter fudge
well something about like the texture it
almost has like a waxy kind of texture
that's like really appealing so yeah
another one was a maple fudge i had one
time that i didn't go back and look oh i
got some of that a lot well i got some a
long time ago um if you go to saint
augustine there's um what the [ __ ] is
the name of that place
there's a
really old school like candy making
stuff it's been there for like a zillion
years and they make their own fudge on
site yeah and they do all different
flavors and they have one that's maple
they have like a maple one and i think
they have a maple one that maybe has
pecans in it yeah and it is out of this
world it's really really good i think
last time i was in st augustine i did go
there i didn't get any maple though i
think i got um i think i got the mint
chocolate chip and they just sell it in
like little hunks
like a quarter pound or half pound or
something like that and you just kind of
slice it off a little bit and yeah yeah
tim if you made that cobbler there's a
bunch of
i'm sure i just gave you the standard
recipe there's a bunch of other ways
where you can round up or round down on
on the uh on the ratios i don't remember
which one i put in the book but there's
one of them where i think it's like one
cup of milk one cup of sugar two cups of
flour that's another one that way
there's no halves
like there's no one and a half cup or
one you don't need that you can just do
them in even
places and which helps you make the it's
a forgiving recipe you know what i mean
well i think that's why people like
cobblers because it's like well whatever
whatever fruits you got around you can
kind of like chuck a bunch of stuff and
usually it comes out okay right so it
doesn't have to be exact okay uh so you
can get into this thing where well i'm
gonna i want a big one so i'm gonna put
three cups of sugar three cups of milk
and you know and six cups of flour and
then i'm gonna put the spices in the
flour and and mix it up first and then
put the fluids in it and then boom there
it is that's another way you can do it
all right so it is a forgiving
recipe
all right when it comes to the
proportions
um and you something
putting vanilla in it helps
you don't actually have to have the
vanilla there's a bunch of ways you can
get around stuff so that so
but
um i don't remember the exact recipe we
put in the book but it was probably just
the basic one that was
simple but just know that you can change
that recipe you can tweak it quite a bit
and it will still make a cobbler
that was just a general guideline
and you don't and it doesn't have to be
peach
you can take sliced apples that have
been cooked and candied and sugar see
that's what i like i like apple cobbler
i like cherry cobbler also you can take
any kind of frozen vegetable i like that
more than
peach or berry you can take any kind of
frozen
fruit
cover it in sugar let it thaw
all right and if it sits in that sugar
long enough it'll be it'll turn into a
syrup if you don't have time put it into
a pot and cook it into a syrup you can
even do something like
any kind of fruit including cranberries
sugar
cook it
and then pour that on top of the [ __ ]
cobbler mix and bake anything
so don't limit yourself
even if it was just pineapple
you're kind of making pineapple upside
down cake if you do it that way
you could probably do it and come to
think of it you could do it with
chocolate
you could have it yeah i guess you could
you could make a chocolate it probably
wouldn't look all that pretty but it
probably tastes good you could just put
a bunch of [ __ ] chocolate chips on
top of it
yeah it would probably look real
terrible no it would look good
it would look good it would come up
around it be like a chocolate cobbler
and then cut it out of there and [ __ ]
serve it with ice cream man it'd be
[ __ ] great
danny rowling says if we were on death
row what would we choose as the final
meal
ooh that's hard
there was one guy who was they were
executing him for killing a bunch of
kids i don't remember what his name was
he was uh mentally uh
handicapped and um
he uh he saved his dessert for after the
execution yeah ain't that some [ __ ] well
because he wasn't
it's about it for after
they were okay all right
they didn't need to tell them that
there's not gonna be i wonder if one of
the guards eat it would that be [ __ ]
up yeah well hey don't let this
cheesecake get away or whatever the [ __ ]
you couldn't fully grasp what was
happening
i'm that's really hard because it's um
because i love food and i love like
pretty much everything yeah and it would
be really hard if i like narrow it down
it's i don't know it'd have to be
something that i was like oh boy i can
eat something without having to worry
about getting fat cause they're gonna
kill me um
mine would be a breakfast food
yeah i'd be tempted too like i really
like i don't know man like some belgian
waffles or something
or something like that honestly i might
you know
i i think i'd go like the old school
grandpa route and do like a big ass rare
steak yeah and a big old baked potato
and
for dessert i want uh
a slice of cheesecake yeah and a big ol
uh powdered donut with like white icing
and that's right they work and maybe a
little herb boston cream or both like i
said i'm not going to get fat so i can
eat of course you know
i figure if i eat myself into a into a
food coma then i won't be too like upset
about getting electrocuted
getting there or getting the [ __ ]
the injection or whatever
but that's like really hard i don't know
i guess i'm saying like a big-ass steak
because we don't really make steak all
that often but i love like a big
really rare
thick steak
and i just never get it that much i mean
it's too expensive and it's like and if
you go
to
a steak house
i mean they way overcharge
so
yeah tammy said it made it nine by
thirteenth pen yeah yeah yeah that was
probably what i stipulated in the recipe
but uh i only have one of those i got
two of the much bigger ones what are
they [ __ ] something by 24
12 by 24 pads you have to double up on
it
yeah and sometimes when i make a cobbler
i'm like well i'm gonna make enough all
right i might make two
you know
and eat off of them for like a week
that way i have a pre-made dessert and
[ __ ] we get a piece every every meal
i make there's a little bit of cobbler
at the end it's just a whole southern
tradition you know [ __ ] you
southerners [ __ ] know what i'm
talking about you know it's one of the
things we used to do
but see that's what i said i think
that's kind of why i have like a lot of
struggle with it because i grew up in
this house eating that [ __ ] and it's
almost kind of like you had to have
dessert i'm not going to say how to have
dessert after every meal yeah but
a lot of times like you'd have lunch and
it wouldn't be like a real excessive
lunch you just have like a can of chef
boyardee or a bologna sandwich or
something and then my grandmother be
like here have some dessert like a
little debbie cake or something yeah and
then like you'd have dessert like after
dinner too and i'm just like i really
have to stop eating like that because
it's like that's a lot of calories yeah
it's a lot of caffeine well this
southern food is soul food it's the same
we eat the same thing
if you go trace back to the [ __ ]
real traditional southern foods like you
have over
over there at um [ __ ] uh what's her
name's restaurant
down in stanford what's her name uh [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] head injuries got to me um
yeah over shawn tales but you'll see
that
southern food and soul food are the same
thing it's just
southern food is black people food the
black people
it's southern food it's the same [ __ ]
thing okay so that particularly haven't
been there in a long time yeah um
black families had slightly different
twists on it
but the twists that they would use are
not are not you know is the same kind of
twists our families would use or we
there's a lot of crossover
you'd see like oh yeah we use that too
and this [ __ ] goes all the way back to
depression era civil war era before that
some of the stuff so
well that's what cobbler is an ancient
recipe
is soul food too black people eat that
eat the [ __ ] out of that and so we were
eating it too it goes all goes way back
and it you could make that out of canned
stuff
that went back to the depression era
you know that that was the advantage
because
in the old old south there was no
refrigeration it was ice boxes
and a lot of people couldn't afford ice
or
they could afford ice but they lived so
far away from the [ __ ] ice house
that you know you
it was a pain in the ass to go get a
block of ice and put it in the ice box a
lot of people just learned yeah like
sometimes like the if you depending on
where you lived like the truck would
come the truck and like bring like ice
blocks but some houses were in the
middle of nowhere and they went on a
route for the [ __ ] truck and you know
it's the same thing with milk you know
so they were eat they were
a lot of recipes were designed for
canned evaporated milk or can't you
which is that's how you another way you
could get milk
evaporated milk
or condensed
they used that too
so
all those old southern recipes involved
cans
pre-pre-refrigeration
well i was gonna say too you can kind of
understand uh particularly you know
people of our grandparents generation
that were like depression era you can
understand why they put like why they
made everything a bacon grease and [ __ ]
like that was because they didn't have a
lot so they were kind of trying to like
make stuff taste better and like have
extra calories and stuff like that
without spending too much money so they
were trying to like use everything up
yeah but
now that we kind of have abundance
everywhere yeah it's just you're piling
calories on top of calories so we don't
really need all of that anymore but back
then i mean yeah back then they called
it renderings
and when you cooked things things were
rendered from it you saved that
you cooked bacon you kept the grease
you cooked chicken you kept the the oils
and the greases same thing with beef you
kept tallow they did and then they ended
up making other things with that
renderings
like i said you couldn't waste anything
you couldn't waste anything which i mean
that's i mean that's a good thing to do
anyway yeah like whether you're eat
every bit of that damn animal
eat every bit of it
the thing is though is that if we live
in a time of plenty now if you're
constantly eating pork grease and
[ __ ]
towels you're gonna have a bad time
it'll build up
they weren't eating that much of it
because they didn't have as much as we
as we did
yeah that's what i'm saying so it's kind
of shitty because right you you know if
you grew up in the south and you had
like grandparents or parents are from
that generation you got used to eating
that way because that's how they ate but
they ate that way because they kind of
had to we don't really have to and when
income started to go up in the 50s and
60s they ate just like they did back in
the olden days they just had more of it
more
and when that happened you started
having health problems like my dad was
born drinking bacon grease
his mama would take
milk and stuff
put it in a bottle and put
pork drippings and bacon grease in the
damn bottle
shake it put hair in your chest yeah
that was it make him strong and healthy
so i mean that's what that means that's
yeah that's what all that my dad would
do a quadruple bypass you know by the
time he was you know
in his life and he has diabetes and
diabetes yes and they just ate sugar
upon top of sugar on top of sugar
because his mom was depression era
south and uh all the recipes were
oriented towards the maximization of
what you had
and [ __ ] staples like fats and sugars
and flour and everything fried
pork upon pork upon pork
cream upon cream just and when the
incomes went up they continued to eat
like that but they expanded the volume
when before it was a little bit that
they were eating
of that
and too much of a good thing what you
know
catches up with you
and like i said it's delicious and you
can eat like that sometimes
yeah um just don't you can't do it every
day though i ate that three times one
day i mean you can but yeah
you're gonna have a bad time they ate
breakfast
dinner and supper that's what that was
the orders that they had
breakfast dinner and supper
and they ate that
they ate that three eight eight that
kind of stuff three times a day
every day of the week
on the clock
pouring [ __ ] tallow and bacon grease
in grits just eating that just
it is delicious
absolutely delicious
yeah really [ __ ] good
heart attack waiting to happen yeah and
you know
african americans have the highest rate
of [ __ ] heart disease and [ __ ]
hypertension and and and
and what do you call it uh diabetes
and it's partly because of that diet
black people still eat like that
and even more so than a lot of a lot of
people white people in the south there
aren't as many white people back in
certain areas like mississippi as there
used to be but a lot of the problems
that you see like you know we're like oh
man black people have all these diabetes
problems it's the diet
it's the diet it's it's like an old
school diet
yeah it'll catch up with you to catch up
to you like i said you can do it every
now and then it won't hurt you but yeah
like for a treat
but yeah yeah you can't eat like my
dad's the same way
my dad would take a [ __ ] he'll take a
[ __ ]
glass and put rc cola in it and then
pour a whole pack of salted peanuts in
it
and just start drinking remember that
[ __ ] yeah
that's some old mostly they did it with
pepsi i kind of feel like most people
did it with pepsi yeah they did it with
pepsi but my dad was cause pepsi is real
sweet sweeter so the sweet and salty
like went really good together yeah
but uh my dad [ __ ]
always claimed that rc was like that was
the real
soda
that was that was like real so it for
him the other [ __ ] was fake i saw
on youtube uh company man did a video
about rc cola like not too long ago
i don't even know is it still around
right i mean you can still buy it yeah i
just think it's it doesn't have much
market share though they have it over at
the general store here yeah it's good i
mean i never i don't i don't drink soda
so i don't know it's good i like it
um it's a little sweeter than pepsi i
would say and pepsi is sweeter than coke
yeah it's a little although i don't
really see
everybody says that but i'm not really a
soda connoisseur like i said i've never
been a big soda fan yeah so to me they
all kind of taste similar i can't really
if you if you blindfolded me and i don't
know if i could tell one from the other
to be honest with you another one they
drank was knee high
yeah especially knee high peach they
love that one
my dad got pissed in the [ __ ] 80s
when they changed the recipe though
uh because the and i remember both
recipes i liked them both but the old
one was more like cream soda with a
peach flavor and then the newer one was
like really really peachy and [ __ ]
almost a neon orange neon yellow
yellowish orange or peach color
it did it did taste a little more
artificial
i liked them both
but the old one was and it was sugar on
the old one instead of [ __ ] corn
syrup
did they have a strawberry knee-high
yeah okay i like the strawberry one yeah
yeah they had peach i don't like peach
flavored stuff though the p the old
peach was much better than the new peach
i remember the grape one being okay yeah
although it wasn't my first pick it was
grape
strawberry
peach and orange
that was the yeah the orange was good
too yeah i'm more like strawberry orange
cherry type person i'm not really into
like peach grape it can go either way
sometimes grape soda is good but you got
to be in the mood for it only from what
i remember of knee high it was just
fruit flavors
i don't remember them having a cola or a
seven no i don't think they did i think
it was all free kind of like fanta
man i used to like new york seltzer you
guys remember that yeah yeah black
cherry was good
uh dave says last meal spaghetti
meatballs lots of meat sauce that's a
good pick i was actually thinking of
something italian too but we make
italian food a lot so maybe that's why i
was trying to pick something that we
don't have as much
you know what i mean
um and then he says chantelle's has the
best catfish oh my god who said that
dave did oh hell yeah yeah all their
food i mean their their shrimp and grits
is yeah fantastic [ __ ] was really the
chicken david goes there too man yeah i
post it up because it's right there like
by mannequins it's like literally like
two or three doors down yeah i got some
videos of of uh of jenny and mannequins
i'll show it again
just for you guys who don't know what
we're talking about not mannequins uh
it's up the street from mannequins but
it's uh yeah it's like right there and
it's usually open all night now
i mean if you go in the middle of the
night i think it's open till 4am
but if you go in the middle of the night
they only have a limited menu yeah so
you can get chicken and waffles and you
can get like a few other things but if
you want like shrimp and grits or
catfish or something like that usually
you have to go back in the daytime but
we've been in the daytime a few times
and i got their shrimp and grits a
couple times and they were like really
really good yeah i'm trying to get a
picture of
jenny
at there it is
here's jenny
and that's at chantal's and i'm lusting
on her boobs and stuff and she's let's
see fault yeah i'm going yeah yeah i was
[ __ ] loaded and i'm going like i'm
gonna guess that that shot
it went red first oh it's okay it's okay
okay that's chantal's
it's a really good soul food restaurant
it's got a dj that's their karaoke thing
yeah because they do a lot or i don't
know if they do karaoke anymore but they
did for a long time it's in uh sanford
yeah downtown san francisco downtown
staffordshire like i said it's only like
a little bit away from
it's it's like right there yeah
it's not right next to mannequins
because they're mannequins and then
there's like a a lot where you can park
like a dirt lot
and then there's one other thing and
then there's chantel that's us that's
eating with some people at chantal oh
that's right we ran into remember that
yeah i remember that trying to see i
can't remember what their name for i
forgot what it is that little couple
broke up quick they weren't around
for a while he moved here from
california
she's still around i've seen her coming
out in and out a couple times
there's another one jenny
sitting at chantals
dj maniac says i can still get mellow
yellow in some of those coke 1000
machines man i forgot all about mellow
yellow i used to kind of like that like
i said i don't know i just never even
when i was a kid
you know i said like soda was just kind
of like man
i liked it i was like i don't know i
don't know why it's like sometimes if
i'm well the thing about it is that if
that's all that was available like if
you were at someone's house like for a
party or something like that or if
you're at a restaurant they didn't
really have anything else to drink
then i'd be like okay well i'll just get
like sprite or 7up or ginger ale or
something like that but
honestly even when i was growing up i
was like a weird ass kid all i wanted to
drink was ice water
or
milk with ice in it
that's about it there was an orange
juice sometimes if i had it lynne was
sly who's a fail he's a fellow uh
us army
korea veteran
he's saying that
harvard yale humanities 101 course fails
in comparison to learning from thomas
that is true that is true well they're
going to [ __ ] not tell you
another good source of what we're
talking about of southern history would
be thomas soule
he's done a lot of little videos and
[ __ ] um would like expel he would
kind of like um um [ __ ] dispel a
bunch of myths about the way it was back
then he had he has a lot of information
because they
they tailored a lot after the civil war
they tailored a lot of the history of
the united states
to be very pro-union because they're
trying to hold the states together
so they kind of left a lot of the story
out when it came to the south
uh in the south ended up just being
coming demonized
over the years especially by hollywood
and
california and new york they were the
ones that mostly were behind let me go
to the restaurant
yeah
kanavatsan says need to make a
shrimp chile rienos tacos that sounds
really good yeah
um and you said you sent him the recipe
okay well i'll get him to make it one of
these days one of these days because man
i love seafood i'll eat seafood anything
pretty much
yeah dave says we go for mannequins
closes we used to as well we haven't
been lately because like i said i'm
trying not to because i have a tendency
like when i go out and drink
then like after i'm there for a couple
hours like i have a few drinks i dance
and stuff i'm like man i'm hungry and i
always want either chantelle's or
i want uh
like mcdonald's breakfast food like i
always want like a sausage and egg
mcmuffin or some [ __ ] because i always
like i like breakfast food uh like early
in the morning you know what i mean for
a long time we used to sometimes we'd
stop at ihop or we'd stop at like waffle
house or something like that but now
that a lot of stuff isn't open 24 hours
anymore it's like a lot harder so
but i'm really trying not to do that i'm
trying not to get because i'm usually so
good about not pigging out but sometimes
i'll get drunk and be like [ __ ] it i'm
really hungry and i just like want
something like super fattening so i'm
trying i've been trying not to do that
last time we went out we went to when we
went to memento mori well i wasn't like
i wasn't all that drunk because all we
had was all i had was a couple beers and
a couple of those little five percent
alcohol cans so i was just like not even
buzzed really but
i was kind of hungry but then i was like
now i'll resist it so i weeded
i was like that's i'm sure i drank
enough calories just i didn't want to
like eat anything else
but you know that's so all i've eaten
today is
a little bowl like tom made some butter
chicken like a big huge pot of it so
we've been eating like a little bit off
that
like every day for lunch so i just had a
little bit bitty bowl of that that's all
i've had today actually cause i didn't
have any breakfast i just had i had two
cups of coffee
and some gum
that's all i had for breakfast
and then i like had a little bitty bowl
of butter chicken for lunch that's all
that's all i've had i'll eat before we
go out though i'll probably have like
some more butter chicken before we go
out like another small bowl but
i'm gonna try not to eat afterwards i'm
sure i'll want to but
i'm gonna try and i'm gonna try and not
we'll just see how it goes because like
i said i've been doing good the last few
days
i do
i do feel better when i don't eat as
much you know what i mean
because a lot of times like i get hungry
and i'm just kind of like oh i want this
i want to eat all the things but then
like after i eat all the things and i'm
like ah now i feel like crap you know
what i mean like i always feel like
really like really listless and
everything when i eat a lot less i feel
a lot better
it's just hard because
i don't know because food's delicious so
you know what i mean
maybe i need to take that remember back
in the old days i feel like back in the
old days
they would uh when they give ladies that
[ __ ] that drug that made all the food
like smell bad or like taste bad or made
everything seem like unappetizing is
there there's a drug that does that
right
i thought there was that was what the
one of those maybe it was that aids
stuff that they used to give them that
little [ __ ]
chocolate [ __ ] i don't know
oh oh my god
lynnwood slice had never ate shrimp and
grits dad just used salt in our grits
growing up yeah yeah yeah we just put
salt and pepper and like a butter on
them on grits i i put tony sachery
seasoning in them cheese
you can put any kind of bacon bits
bacon grease
or you can put the damn seafood in it
man we got people
up north and in other countries onto the
damn grit subject you got people say tom
what's the grid again they're trying to
get what's it what's the grit yeah when
do grits come in season
what kind of tree does a grit come off
of just all kinds of grit trees when do
the grit trees come in season you know
they ask me all kinds of [ __ ] and i
[ __ ] i'm proud to have spread the
grits phenomena to other countries
that's peanut butter i got germans
eating peanut butter i was gonna say we
even like spread the the gospel of
peanut butter
like to other yeah i mean they have
peanut butter over there it's just
it's just kind of and i and you know
it's a generalization but i do kind of
feel like i don't know about europe in
general but i remember being in the uk
and people thinking like peanut butter
was gross and i'm like well you guys are
obviously wrong because i mean it's like
you know they got some good food over
there like fish and chips and all that
kind of stuff but
i was like peanut butter is delicious
and i don't even know what you're
talking about
and they use peanut butter a lot in like
in like thai food and stuff like that so
it's not weird it's not like it's just
like an american food or something dj
maniac says you ain't getting the fish
fillet after 10 p.m yeah i noticed um
and actually last time when was the last
time it's been a while since it's
probably like a month or something since
we stopped at a mcdonald's drive-thru
like after the club i think it was like
three weeks ago or a month ago and i
think it was a saturday night so they
were open because a lot of times now if
it's a monday night or something like
that then they don't bother because it's
not crowded enough but it was a saturday
night and we stopped and i couldn't even
get
like a chicken
what's that chicken thing that they have
that has the tomato and lettuce on it
chicken club whatever the [ __ ] they call
it i don't know but i like that chicken
sandwich that has all the veggies on it
um but they wouldn't even give me that
they didn't they didn't have no fish and
they didn't have no chicken you could
just so i just was like well [ __ ] it i
just i guess i'm getting a quarter
pounder so i just got a quarter pounder
and i like a cup of coffee
i mean i get it
i get it
but
come on
i did i mean i was like really really
excited
the first time because ever since
i don't even remember when i'd always
been advocating as soon as like
mcdonald's went to like being open 24
hours or a lot of them did i know all of
them aren't but as soon as like i was
just like [ __ ] they should do breakfast
all day because the breakfast is the
best thing i mean they're like sausage
egg mcmuffin i mean sausage mcmuffin
with egg is clearly the best breakfast
sandwich and you can fight me
but it's better than the egg mcmuffin
sorry because i'm not a big fan of that
ham that's on there
but like i was like well they should do
breakfast they could do limited
breakfast all day so they finally did
that and i was like holy [ __ ] they
finally listened
and then
and then they stopped doing it
and i'm like
after i drink all i want is i want a
[ __ ] sausage in my wife and with egg
on it and maybe a hash brown depending
it's nice i grew up on grizz oatmeal and
cream of wheat i forgot all about
creamery yeah i say creamery creamery i
don't even know it's good with all kinds
of stuff yeah cream of wheat is also
good you can put maple syrup in it you
can put chocolate chips in it
you could uh put fruit in it sugar
yeah
i think i think creamery was also called
farina wasn't it i think it was i think
is that the same thing i think it's the
same thing or it's very similar
something very similar
yeah the only problem with cream of weed
is that when it what's same with grits
when it cools off you can never really
revive it it just becomes a hard block
and you can't bring it back so you got
to eat it all the creamy wheat is pretty
good put some cream in it
dry [ __ ] coffee creamer would work in
it with sugar
raisins
and some people like what the [ __ ] is
creamy cream of wheat it was a
it was like a cereal basically
it came out of a [ __ ]
cardboard box or a cardboard tube kind
of like oatmeal would come out of maybe
with a spigot you could pour it
depends on what era it came from
you cooked it in water kind of boiled it
and um then you could season it it was
just wheat
wheat for yeah i remember it being
pretty good i mean you can't just i mean
you can just eat it plain but it's just
kind of like oatmeal it's like you
always have to kind of put something in
it yeah like everybody puts something
like if you're gonna put oatmeal like if
you're gonna make oatmeal like oatmeal
is good but it's much better if you put
like some cinnamon in there you cut some
fruit up or yeah you know you gotta like
tart it up a little bit
people outside the south probably would
be like wow that's awful basic
yeah it's basic
but that's what they had back then
although you'd be surprised
how good of a little meal you could get
out of that you wouldn't even think of
it you can spice that up and dress that
up into something that's delicious
you know that's the whole secret of
being a good cook or a good chef anyways
it takes something that nobody else
wants and turned into something special
and you could do that with oatmeal cream
of wheat
we'll see the thing about grits oatmeal
like stuff like that i kind of think of
those the same way that i think about
like pasta or potatoes or something like
that it's like it's like the canvas yeah
yeah you know you need like things to
put on there like to you know to make it
like a work of art yeah it's just your
baseline
europeans and northerners like what is
the [ __ ] great grit is a [ __ ]
what it ends up being is a lot like
polenta
it's a lot like polenta
uh and polenta
especially european polenta is always
gonna be spiced you have like italian
versions of greek birds it's got cheese
in it and [ __ ] herbs and
what it is
is it's made out of harmony
if you see a harmony it looks like a
[ __ ] white [ __ ] explosion
all right like a poof oh and it's a
piece of popcorn it's essentially pop
it's popcorn but it's wet
and what they would do is they would
take
cracked feed corn but that's the corn
that you give to cattle you take that
and you put it into a [ __ ] 50 gallon
oil drum
55 gallon oil drum you put water in
there with it and a bunch of lye and the
lie breaks it down and [ __ ]
chemically and pops it like popcorns
yeah inside this
big [ __ ] fit drum
you know they kind of look like curds
yeah like if you're like if you're from
canada and they have that thing like
like poutine yeah it kind of looks like
that it doesn't taste the same but
that's kind of what it looks like now
you got this big drama of [ __ ] water
filled with [ __ ] pop
wet popcorn basically
and uh
you can pull some out of there over time
and it's sterile nothing's gonna happen
to that [ __ ] it's preserved you don't
need refrigeration that's why they were
eating it
you can take that and [ __ ] heat it up
boil it in something and then kind of um
you can eat it just like that harmony
with [ __ ] salt pepper you could buy
it in cans you still can't stop it don't
buy it might grab my hand around here
salt pepper and butter just like it was
popcorn but you have it as a side dish
like along with beans or rice and [ __ ]
harmony
well you could take harmony then
and instead of leaving it whole
you could hit it with a whisk
and break it up
into like a uh
until into like a uh not a mush
it's like polenta you don't want to whip
it till trump comes fluid it's just
little bitty pieces all right
so you take the harmony and you break it
up into little bitty pieces by kind of
like blending it
once it's blended
you can eat it like that or you could
dehydrate it
all right now they probably had in a
factory what they would do is they'd
probably dehydrate the piece of harmony
and then once it was dry then break it
up into little pieces yeah that seems
like that's probably the easiest way to
do it sure
i never made it that way i've just only
prepared it
so what you end up with when you get
grits is a big old [ __ ] bag like a
[ __ ] two and a half pound bag
of little white
things that looks like
busted up pieces of rice i guess
kind of what it's like imagine rice but
instead of grains it's more like the
size of uh
a [ __ ] black ground black pepper
okay but it's white
you boil that in water put salt pepper
and
butter in it and that's a side dish
that's the beginnings of a side dish and
you can season it with
cheese and throw
shrimp in it or pieces of bacon or you
can put pork as a side next to bacon and
eggs with toast
for your breakfast
grits is nothing to laugh at man it's
[ __ ] good it has a
it's like a corn polenta
that's the best way i can describe it it
tastes like corn kinda
but like i said if you eat it plain yeah
there's not much to it it doesn't really
it just kind of tastes like yeah nothing
right pretty much
but so you always have to like nothing
with a hint of corn yeah yeah like corn
paste yeah but like i said you gotta put
some i mean but it's good with just
butter salt and pepper yeah it's good
enough just like that but you can do
other [ __ ] with it
dj maniacs like mcdonald's uh tried
all-day breakfast for a while because
the stoners were mad they never got up
in time for more i know man right i mean
the thing about i mean what kind of
[ __ ] is that stop in serving
breakfast at 10 30 a.m i can't get there
by 10 30 and i get up early okay he
knows
i get up like between 6 30 and 7 every
morning but by the time i get up get
like work done get [ __ ] like that like
take a shower put makeup on [ __ ] like
that i can't get there by 10 30. i'm
sorry it's not gonna happen
so when it comes to mcdonald's that fish
fillet
maniac was talking about get the double
fish fillet set which is so much better
i'm amazed that they that it took them
this long to figure that out like that
because i i liked the fish filet
sandwich before
but the double one i kind of feel like
the ratio is more correct
now i will say that if you get the
single one and this is just i mean uh
you know this depends on the on the
mcdonald's you go to i guess and who's
working that day yeah but a lot of times
if i get a fish fillet it has too much
tartar sauce yeah like i gotta scrape
about half of it off slices uh tom never
used fruit and cream of wheat you are
correct
yeah you are correct sir and he and he
gets it all the way up in philadelphia
yeah
well what happened was [ __ ] after the
war after the civil war when black
people
migrated north to get out of the south
and they took their diet with them and
when they got into the north they called
it soul food
but back in the south it's just southern
food
but no you can eat it with the cream of
wheat is [ __ ] great with with fruit i
don't know if you ever had it but any
kind of berries or
diced up pieces of apple that have been
[ __ ] cooked and caramelized with salt
with excuse me with sugar and and and
cinnamon you know what i mean cube it up
cook it in a little bit of butter with
cinnamon
that's my favorite thing to put into
oatmeal and so it's pretty much like the
same just like opiates and drop it in
there and just kind of swirl it in there
so you got swirls and put a little pad
of butter on top of that
now you don't want to do that first
thing in the morning
okay you want to make
that apple
um
uh that [ __ ]
what it called
your apple topping is basically talking
about you want to make that a long time
before you want to keep something like
that in the refrigerator in a in a in a
tupperware container or jar
i was watching uh one of those videos
the other day about you know eat for
five ten dollars a week or something
and the girl on there she's like i found
this recipe on like [ __ ] you know
tick tock or some [ __ ] like that
and she was trying to replicate i can't
i don't know if it was dunkin donuts or
somewhere but that she's like they have
these little breakfast things they're
like little balls but they're like apple
cinnamon like oatmeal
balls yeah and she's like they're pretty
easy to make and you can make them ahead
of time
and then like just freeze them and then
like when like so make like a whole
bunch like on sunday or whatever and
then like get up in the morning and you
can just kind of like heat them up and
have a couple with your coffee or
whatever and they looked like really
really good
i can't remember what fast food
restaurant does on though because like i
said i don't really david parker goes
farina with sugar well finally home from
work gonna get my sloppy joes so i'll be
with all man witch ready for tonight's
witch ball man witch man which
mannequins uh uh gonna try to get a
quick quick nap we'll love you both
maybe jenny moore huck
excuse me sly says i get the fish
sandwich take the cheese off and just
use the tartar sauce and then that's
fine
um
polenta trying to donate to you guys
channel instruct me how to i'm old
school uh if you're set up to do a super
chat you can super send us a super chat
but i don't know if your account is set
up for that
if not you can um
uh
probably the other way would be going to
go through patreon
no you kind of think you can do it one
time no you can contact jenny at her at
her facebook
and uh
send her uh money to her inst uh what do
you call it her paypal her paypal
yeah because yeah some people have done
that yeah do you actually you could
probably give your paypal just over uh
well i'd have to get my email in yeah
that's right that's right yeah i'd have
to give money she could send you a way
to do it yeah
um here's another one here's another one
slide i don't have you ever heard of
this one because you up in [ __ ]
pennsylvania
or is it philadelphia is it philadelphia
pennsylvania well philadelphia is in
pennsylvania yeah well he's one of the
other okay anyway um
we have something here called apple
butter
we should be a part of
that should be a part of soul food that
that should have
should be up there by now it's it's kind
of like
cooked pureed apples that you put into a
jar you jar it
and uh we use it as a spread kind of
like jelly
uh it's kind of like cooked applesauce
spice really good
i don't think i've ever seen
seen it sold
in a store you could probably buy it
around here
well i've never really looked for it so
probably and you would think that apple
butter well you would think that
you know for example like states that
were really known for it for apples like
washington state for example you would
think that they would know they would
probably like sell that i would imagine
because that seems like a pretty well
yeah
the old the old generations of the south
were real big on apple butter if they
saw you using jelly they'd kind of look
at you a little bit sideways you sure
you sure you're going to get jelly we
got apple butter
and that's clean that's like the real
it's clearly way better yeah
i mean jelly is good too
it's all good like i said all food all
food is pretty much delicious
well not all foods it was a
thing of ethnic pride though they were
like you're going to put jelly on that
we got apple butter
it's like oh what's the matter with you
yeah are you a communist
right because they'd put apple butter on
a peanut butter sounds like some [ __ ] my
grandpa would say
yeah you might be communists
yeah cause they put apple butter on a
[ __ ] peanut butter and jelly sound
chip that's apple butter
yeah
um yeah i had that i took that to school
a couple of times and i knew like some
other kids that you took that as well
yeah
usually i had pb and j though yeah i
like it with or you know okay this is
how what a weird kid i was
i liked
like i would take pb j sometimes
i liked for my mom
to make grilled cheese sandwiches the
night before and wrap them in wax paper
and put them in my lunch so they were
nice and kind of cold and greasy the
next day i don't know why i liked that
so much but i liked cold grilled cheese
sandwiches yeah in my lunch so
it's like i said that [ __ ] i'd heard
of apple butter my mom grandma put it on
on white toast yeah yeah that's it
yeah first time i saw it my grandmother
gave it to me too
and uh man it was good and they made it
they made it
and so and so if you're
if your grandmother and being black if
your grandmother and your mom gave you
that [ __ ] it is soul food then that's
what it would be called up north soul
food in the south it was just food
but that was
making me want to make apple butter i
haven't had in a long time
maybe maybe we should yeah
i really like i really like gotta go
down and get some apples cook them up
make apple butter out of it and because
it'd be a lot easier today because i
have [ __ ] immersion blenders
yeah
yeah it's just a cooked apple you
[ __ ] blend it
there is your apple butter
yeah put that [ __ ] in a jar
they were jarring it though they put it
in a damn mason jar and [ __ ] cook it
inside the mason jar again and get all
to kill all the bacteria and it would
just preserve like that
say
well that's how you pretty much yeah
preserve any furs already but they were
preserving it it was a way of saving an
apple
and uh
that was southern jelly
basically southern jam
granthary says old polish men in
michigan love head cheese sandwiches
it's good [ __ ] they have [ __ ] head
cheese down the south too
louisiana head cheese is some of the
best yeah my grandpa likes kind of
cheese oh [ __ ] he likes head cheese and
he liked um scrapple scrappled like he
would eat scrapbook yeah
some people don't know what the he's and
he's from tennessee like what the [ __ ]
is he she was from head cheese you take
a [ __ ] head of a hog and you [ __ ]
cook it down and spice it and then once
it's all cooked you pull all the meat
off the damn skull of that head that
that
that pig and it's all chopped and diced
and it's turned into a damn loaf and
then you cool it it's a pig head load
it's a pig head loaf it's kind of like
[Laughter]
and then you and then it becomes kind of
gelatinous and you slice off slices of
it and put it on toast and eat it cold
oh man it's good well i mean you do that
i don't do that oh it's real good
if the spicy is correct it's better than
[ __ ] any [ __ ] cold i've had it
before i'm just i'm not a fan it's a
it's you know it's okay yeah it's just
not anything that i i love care to eat
again i love it i like the the the
louisiana versions of it because it was
it was spicy
it's it was like if you like cold
cuts you know like ham and cheese
sandwich you'd like head cheese
all right it's even better than ham it's
just like whoa
and same thing cheese mayo all that
real good john goris says the
hitchhiker's fave yeah from texas
chainsaw massacre head cheese by the way
that was if you remember yeah he got in
the van it was talking about head cheese
it's diced up and turned into a loaf so
it's not like uh
you don't ever see
pieces of anything off of a head you
know what i mean it's not the it's just
that's this little eyeball staring at me
how funny would that really yeah
they should do that just for [ __ ]
giggles it's like it's not a real
eyeball the same way they make salami
it's actually
salami would be worse because it
probably has [ __ ] guts and intestines
in [ __ ] at least the stuff that's coming
off that [ __ ] head
is is meat
i mean it's no when you think about it
really technically it's no weirder than
like a hot dog or a sausage exactly
because they just like grind up whatever
meats left over like snouts and whatever
and just put it in a casing and i eat
hot dogs
right but it's less disgusting than a
hot dog it's a lot better quality real
good was that kids in the hall that said
that
that hot dogs are made of what lips and
[ __ ] and old phone books and [ __ ]
like that um grantor said head cheese
gives you poop breath just saying no
well you would think that he would know
because they eat that they eat that [ __ ]
like no okay well maybe i've never
really like smelled anyone's that might
be this this i never got close enough to
my grandpa after he ate it that might be
the spicing that they're using up there
the poop spices yeah yeah in the south
no it was just like it was good the
member of the spice girls that nobody
talks about yeah
yeah she's poop spice uh she's the
scatological member of the baby cam guys
cooking it down milk and a half regular
price heavy cream double
okay i don't know what he's telling cam
guys talking about [ __ ]
mixed apple jelly into the peanut butter
cook it down for hours okay
do they sell apple butter i'm gonna buy
yours tom uh yeah you can you could
probably buy apple butter you just have
to look for you probably tammy said look
around peanut butter and jelly section
the grocery store should see apple
butter there my white northern family
has eaten it forever okay all right yeah
yeah
yeah like it's i kind of feel like
nowadays everything is everywhere
everything is pretty much everywhere
there maybe are a few like outlier
things that are regional but i kind of
feel like that's not really the case
anymore just particularly like i said
because the internet because everything
and like i said everybody's foodies now
so everybody knows everything about
everything yeah
the information has gotten out it's
easier to get
every i mean because
it was like hard to get
what they call ethnic ingredients right
down here in florida like when i was a
kid growing up like i said if you wanted
chinese food it was like that lachoy
[ __ ] in the can right and if you wanted
like mexican food it was like the ortega
or whatever like the box taco kids
terrible [ __ ] that was about it not now
but now you can get pretty much anything
you want yeah we're kind of at the edge
of the city you can go right up the
[ __ ] road [ __ ] two miles up there
and we can have a sushi [ __ ] meal i
guess we even post a video on it
it's better than anything i used to get
in boston when i lived in boston better
than that
for a fraction of the price and it's
nice in there all black and red and
[ __ ] looks like a damn
japanese pagoda i like their shrimp
yeah like in the bento box yes all the
that comes with like a couple of sushi
guys too it's good i don't think there's
japanese people working in there they're
probably chinese but [ __ ] it's it's
good
whatever as long as the food's good yeah
yeah i don't care who's working in there
as long as a bunch of white girls
waitresses big old booties [ __ ] slide
love it
whoever runs that place [ __ ] to
whoever run whoever whatever chinese
dude runs that place you got to be a big
booty country girl to be working in
there
do you notice that jenny no i do you
didn't notice that they're all big why
would i notice something like that yeah
well i know you you sometimes partake
but i just thought that maybe you'd like
notice like
all these girls well it's not usually so
i mean like i'm in a restaurant i'm just
like thinking about what kind of food i
want to eat i'm not like thinking about
like people's butts i'll point it out
next time
look at that girl's [ __ ] it's not
really i have lots of other things on my
big old little waist i know dudes are
kind of just like you know
this much of their brain is like
concerned with like boobs and butts and
like then everything else is just like
in this very small area right here this
[ __ ] i have like a whole bunch of other
things going on this area is all farms
horse ranches and cattle farms
um
with
rich people that own mansions
somewhere right over there it's all
hidden and said a lot of these rich
[ __ ] you didn't even see you go
in there like that and [ __ ] mansions
just hidden in them trees it looks like
uh
it looks like a [ __ ] forest with a
discreet entrance and then you go in
there and it's a housing development
well you shouldn't go in there because
you might get shot at it right yeah
and they're who are you
out there
and they're the houses of [ __ ] people
that
are millionaires that live in dam new
york and california
uh
have houses here sometimes lots of
houses here
and um they want all their [ __ ] the
economy here is pretty much thriving it
kind of reminds me of
vista in oceanside california back in
the 70s when i was a kid that's that's
kind of the same kind of environment
it's a mixture
of english towns like over there and
then like
spanish-style stuff spanish towns and
but because of all these farms you have
farm girls and uh then you have a lot of
uh
legal central
we don't really have illegal immigration
here
that you can see the ones that are here
they're all legal and they're [ __ ]
working in these farms uh working with
animals and uh you know chicken farms
[ __ ] cattle ranches
and
uh horse farms
so there's a whole network of mexican
and central american stuff here they got
one of the best mexican restaurants i've
ever been in right over here at this
mexican store just up the street what's
the name of that place by the way i
don't know
i never look at the name of it it's just
like in a strip mall yeah like on the
side of like a country road it's like a
grocery store too like half of it's a
grocery store and then half of it's a
restaurant yeah it's owned by a mexican
woman and her son runs it most of the
time i was hanging out with the son sons
sun's into [ __ ] he's in the
bodybuilding a little bit
uh he's in his early 20s
and man you talking about guacamole the
best guacamole ever i was showing
pictures of it to kanavatsan pictures of
what they were serving because yeah
that's it that's it it's really you can
go get awaka cheese and all the mexican
real mexican ingredients they're all in
there i'm gonna have to go up there i
haven't eaten there in like years and
years yeah and it's not that expensive
and uh
every day i was in there eating and
[ __ ] like 50 dudes came in there and
eat one by one getting a little bags
plastic and then running off and they
were giving them lunch
they were selling them like a daily
lunch yeah
in a paper bag to take out
and um
because they're they're they're feeding
all the all the ranch hands around here
they probably maybe they have like a
contract or something like that where
there's just kind of like yeah we'll
make this many lunches for people like
for x amount of dollars yeah they all
came in at the same time like about 50
of them pick it up and and i was looking
at what they were getting man they were
getting really good like
stews and soups and pieces of bread and
like a piece of chicken and some rice
and tortillas and they're making
tortillas in there they make their own
corn tortillas and it's like hot it's
i'm in there i mean the only white dude
in there and all these mexicans and [ __ ]
you know what i mean they're eating and
we're just looking at each other going
damn this shit's good and i say it's wet
and they're like yeah we went you know
look at that
they're eating it too man it's looking
it's good
like being in mexico mexican food so
good next yeah i mean
most food is good their authentic [ __ ]
is mexican food yeah but they have all
pastor and all the different kinds of
stuff you know
anything you ask for you know you know
they have specials and the prices are
reasonable real reasonable
one of these days we'll go back and eat
up there like you've eaten there a
couple of times like when you were out
yeah because when you were like out on a
ride and stuff it's just we never really
go up that way i don't think i've eaten
there since
since that girl was since that girl was
here and that's her nephew oh it's oh
it's much better now yeah it's a
different chef i mean it was good then
but it's a different chef and his
[ __ ] is great great lyrica dude
says a bear took scrapple out of my ice
chest once i was like good on him
because he did me a favor
why'd you even have it in your cooler in
the first place
why'd you even bring it with you if you
didn't want to eat it
i don't know i'm not hating like i don't
you know if you want to eat that that's
fine like i said my my grandparents used
to eat it my grandma used to eat
remember they probably still have this i
don't look but
they used to have
it came in a can't like calves brains in
a can and like you ate it with scrambled
eggs right like calves brains and
scrambled eggs i don't think the
scrambled eggs were in the can but you
could like the cavs marines were and you
just mixed it with scrambled eggs and my
grandma loved that [ __ ] she always had
like cans of that in the uh in the
cupboard as well
and we always had like scrapple
in the fridge
because my grandpa was into it and i was
just kind of i don't know just something
about it kind of grossed me out like i
said
you know logically it's not any
different than a hot dog or a sausage
but
i don't know i i just couldn't get
behind it i don't i can't get behind i
think this is why i don't like spam
i don't really like
a loaf of meat
i mean oh okay maybe that's
okay that's that's too much of a
generalization because i do like
meatloaf
although i didn't when i was younger
but that's technically not a lo i mean
you make that into a loaf it's ground
beef and you make that into a loaf i'm
not really into like that gelatinous
like where it's kind of
that see i think that's what grosses me
out about spam it's like the fact you
opened a can and they're just like
plop i'm just like that's it's not super
appetizing and i kind of feel like maybe
that's why i'm kind of grossed out by
scrapple and stuff even though it's the
same [ __ ] that's in like a hot dog and
stuff i don't know
i mean i don't know there's a there's
lots of other things to eat i'm not
gonna eat that
i'm not gonna eat that but you can eat
it if you want you can eat if you want
kevin says tom cracks me up yeah he's
he's a funny guy he's a funny guy
okay gramster says there is an el salva
uh el salvador and uh pupasaria is that
how you pronounce it in detroit
uh there's stuffed flower pancakes with
cheese pork and jalapenos oh my god that
sounds amazing
that sounds amazing i don't think i've
ever had those but that sounds
that sounds really really good
uh yeah blairde says i was trying it
camping
did you think it would taste better like
when you were outside
then it's like well this is probably
like gross but maybe if i take it
outside and like eat it while i'm
camping then it'll taste better
but the bear ate it so you didn't get to
try it did you try it later on that's
like that's what i'm asking
holy [ __ ] tammy said that her irish
italian grandma
used to can apple butter so yeah so and
that's i guess that's up north so yeah
it's spread around now everybody knows
about it
yeah like i said i think it's really
difficult to find anything that's
regional although you know what's
interesting is here's one thing that i
always find really interesting
i kind of feel like
some
uh restaurant chains fast food chains
you know casual dining chains
are still regional
yeah um stuff like
um like carl's jr like jack-in-the-box
stuff like that we don't have those
like i've heard of them yeah i miss
carl's jr but we don't have those
although uh carl's jr is owned by the
same company that owns hardy's we have
heart
i think that's kind of like the southern
equivalent yeah although the few times
every time i mean it's not as good
hearties is kind of like the
the redheaded stepchild version
carl's jr when i was a kid out in
california or at least the one that was
by our house it was good they used to
have deep fried burritos there didn't
take anything like a burrito just like a
deep in it when those [ __ ] were all
man you could deep fry pretty much
anything and it's delicious
um i don't care what it is i don't know
what carl's jr is like now but back in
back in the 70s early 80s carl's jr's be
really good yeah everybody kind of talks
del taco we have one here
there's two there's one over by ucf yeah
because me and my friend jen used to go
there
um when i used to live over there uh in
winter park i went to it she took me to
the one here it was really good del taco
used to be shitty when i was a kid in
the 70s and the early 80s it was shitty
i like that they have tacos and french
fries yeah
delta
no del taco is good but like i said we
only have two of them and the ones that
we have the one that we have here like
ones away the [ __ ] over by the college
yeah which is where my apartment used to
be like a long time ago it was kind of
close to that i don't remember what the
other one is i think the other one is
over on international drive or something
it's like a really far from here another
one they used to have in california was
a kid they showed it on one on [ __ ]
that uh once upon a time in a hollywood
movie it was it was called derwener
schnitzel that was the case yeah yeah
they weren't good back then they did
like a famous well that's where all the
punks used to have yeah they weren't
very good there was even a song about
that called wienerschnitzel who was it
the dude
was it the descendants yeah
it was it was like mcdonald's but it
sold hot dogs and uh
not good back when i was a kid but they
were just everywhere so you kind of went
just to get it
it's like a thing of opportunity but
that one that they showed he used to
pass it all the time when i was a kid
it's kind of like culturally famous yeah
i mean because even i heard of that [ __ ]
i think i heard of it because probably
because of the descendant song and
because it was like a big like punk rock
hanging out the weird thing here's
what's weird to me
like look at all of the fast food places
that have thrived over the years selling
burgers and like chicken sandwiches and
[ __ ] like that you don't really have one
that sells hot dogs though no it's it's
a loser and the thing about it is that
even some big fast food franchises like
burger king i don't know if mcdonald's
ever did but like i know burger king did
for a while i think wendy's tried for a
while like they tried to do like a hot
dog and it never works out and i don't
know why because hot dogs are something
you buy at a baseball game or there's
something that you buy or that you or
are you are you grill them
yeah
i mean i've [ __ ] i've eaten many hot
dogs just like from a cart like outside
the club that's what they're supporting
that's what [ __ ] like across the street
from ibarr barbarella yeah for a long
time there was a guy that he made vegan
hot dogs yeah and he set up over there
and they were actually pretty good
you know what i mean the texture wasn't
exactly like a hot dog i was wishing it
was meat but i was eating it because i
was drunk but yeah well well and if you
put enough good toppings on it you
didn't really notice it all that much
yeah you were just kind of and it was
still good so i wasn't really bothered
but they had like real ones too and that
and actually the guy that was like right
next to the door of barbarella for a
long time he had like this really good
like kielbasa type sausages those were
good too but i think they regulated it
i think that city of orlando brought in
that law where you couldn't do like the
food truck thing anymore
which is dumb i'm gonna tell you guys
something about this that's dumb because
they were because it used to be used to
be the food trucks would show up yeah
they'd have like the taco thing and
they'd have the hot dog guy and like the
sausage guy and like guy the cake guy
you could yeah you could come out the
club and there was like all like little
like carts everywhere and like you could
eat but they stopped doing that they
they said no you can't do that because
they were beating out all the [ __ ]
restaurants that were paying rent in the
downtown area yes all the restaurants
were mad they were better
because people would [ __ ] go to the
truck instead of people who were paying
rent in downtown
so you complained and that they could
still have food trucks but you couldn't
take them downtown yeah you weren't
allowed to they could only go certain
areas there there was a really good
pizza truck with the [ __ ] super hot
furniture i think it was called 5000
degrees or something like this
yeah it had a name like that and you
never really knew where it was you just
see there's the truck you know i mean
there it is well the thing about it
because for a while yeah you had to be
on their facebook page because for a
long time i don't know if it's still
around but um in orlando there was a
really famous like cupcake truck the
cupcake that's what i meant and yeah and
they had they would do a thing where
it's just like they would do i think two
or four like different flavors like
every day and they were just like crazy
flavors but they would always like move
around and you had to be like on their
facebook group to like find out where
they were going to be that day but they
got like super famous where they made
like all kind of money for a while there
i guess that's about six years now
for a while there you didn't want to own
a restaurant in order or orlando you
wanted to own that one a truck
or like a cart yeah a popular truck
that had a following
kicking [ __ ] ass and they would go
right outside a club
because that could be in
that vegan hot dog cart did a pretty
brisk business like after the bar is
closed yeah he was just a little guy
point yeah it was a cart just a little
cart and he'd stand outside a club and
[ __ ] sell that [ __ ] but he was the
only one doing that yep he was the only
one doing that like doing vegan hot dogs
now like i said the guy that was next to
barbarella he always like set up right
between barbarella and i got a club next
door so i stopped going really yeah
he was selling he did
it was good but i ate one one time and
[ __ ] threw up 20 minutes later i was
like [ __ ] that i ain't eating that no
more you got the [ __ ] best cleavage
going on here jenny hold on let's see
what's going on here see he just gets
like all the streak you can't even
he's pouring the [ __ ] out that's what
he's doing i'm pouring the [ __ ] out of
him
well i took my injections today so
oh boy you're gonna be like one yeah
hard to put up with yeah it wasn't just
one it was two of them god damn it
because deanna ball came
yeah i'm on a slight dose of the animal
super testosterone
great yeah i'm feeling don't be starting
any fight no no no i'm feeling kind of
slick a little bit kind of oily you know
tomorrow off yeah nice moisturizer it's
coming i can tell it's coming tomorrow
me feeling so [ __ ] good
i'm gonna run that for 60 days
and we're gonna see i'm gonna pick up a
couple pounds of muscle and lose a
couple pounds of fat i'm gonna
recomposition i'm gonna be hitting that
[ __ ] gym
hitting that [ __ ] gym over there a
lot
i hit it last night you heard me
i hit the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] last
night i'm i don't know
i was watching stranger things yeah uh
dj maniac says uh derwener schnitzel was
a west coast thing yeah it was he died
in the 70s so did benihana yeah uh
nathan's was the last hot dog
huh kobe is like benihana we got kobe's
here yeah
um nathan's was the last hot dog
franchise and even they dried up here on
the west coast i thought that we still
had a couple nathan's but the last one i
saw was in the airport you don't go to
it so i don't know if it's there anymore
you don't go to a restaurant eat a hot
dog you just don't that's something you
do at home or at a baseball game or or
honestly
like like sam's cafe in the front they
got hot dogs yeah i think they're like a
buck yeah sleep slice a damn pizza out
of the thing you know it's just like
that
another chain that i kind of wish that a
lot of people sort of like rhapsodize
about that we don't have here is culvers
now if anybody lives anywhere where
there's culvers
let me know if it's as good as everybody
claims
because
pretty much everybody that lives
somewhere where there is one is just
like oh culver's like winds like hands
down
but i've never eaten there because we
don't have them i think maybe i think
it's a midwest is it midwest i don't
know but it might be like a western part
of the so so there is some things that
are still regional like in the us like
some restaurants like restaurant chains
and stuff yeah do they have steak and
shakes out west
yeah we got them here man they're always
packed i kind of feel like they don't
yeah
steak shakes pretty good it's pretty
good pretty good i mean their burgers
are it's more like smashed burgers but
they make everything fresh
they're uh their patties aren't frozen
uh and their milkshakes are
phenomenal yeah although i would say
their french fries aren't fantastic
they're more like they're like
shoestring fries but they're okay though
although i say the best hamburger joint
we have here in florida is five guys i
think they have that everywhere guys i
think they even have that in different
countries and you can have all the
french for all these [ __ ] more french
fries than you can [ __ ] eat
my tip if you're going to five guys just
order the small fries yeah because
they're gonna give you they're just
gonna dump them all in the bottom of the
bag anyway
so it's like don't pay for the larger
they're trying to get rid of them damn
fries they're like we have so many
french fries and they make we need to go
we haven't been a long time i think they
make their own french fries yeah they
make them right there they got [ __ ]
bags of potatoes sitting right there
that's why they're trying to get rid of
them all they're like here man give them
fries give them fries yeah so it's like
because sometimes i've gotten like small
fries which is like that big you can
like you go in the bottom of the bag and
it's like half full of french fries i
can't even eat them all and i love
french fries yeah so and i got and their
burgers are big and sloppy
here's something else
this may be part of the fact me and
jenny have the goth factor
okay
the kids that work at all these
restaurants [ __ ] love goth so you
just show up give them some free food
and sometimes it's more
sometimes there's more old golf people
get all kinds of [ __ ] food
did you notice that did we look like we
need it more yeah yeah
i'm getting fat man yeah yeah but like i
said i do love french fries so i do
appreciate that i do i like i really
like five guys yeah five guys for
hamburgers is about the best now do they
have milkshakes i don't think i've ever
had a milkshake yeah i think they do no
i don't know i don't know i think no
it's just soft drinks and you gotta
serve your own yeah they might have some
[ __ ] like that i don't know you guys
focus is on hamburgers and fries they
don't have to go outside that and that's
the way you're they might have a hot dog
they might maybe but i don't know if
they do i think it's hammers or they
might have a chicken sandwich and i
think that's about it
but see that's that's
yeah i kind of feel like if you're gonna
do that yeah then just like focus on
like one thing or like a couple things
and just make those as good as possible
the one we got here right next to it
there's a [ __ ] cold stone where you
get that look at the ice cream creamery
yeah
we haven't been there a long time i
think the last one we went there like
several years ago this is what we'll do
when we when we go see top gun we'll go
do do five guys in cold stone and all
that first or after one or two if i can
eat all that we'll just we'll do five
guys
yeah
i mean cold stone's good too like i'm
always down for ice cream but yeah after
i eat it five guys i'm always just kind
of like oh cold stone to [ __ ] you i'm
gonna
well coldstone we went there one time it
was somebody's birthday it was your
birthday or my birthday yeah and so we
got
like a um it was like what like a
brownie with ice cream and stuff like
that we split it and we still couldn't
finish it yeah
so that's that tells you something right
there i mean that it was a lot
jeffy art says there's a culver's by my
parents house their burgers are pretty
good and the frozen custard is
phenomenal yeah everybody talks about
the frozen question but you'll find
yourself waiting a solid 15 minutes at
least yeah i do kind of feel like that's
sort of one of the ones because i read
like a lot of um
i read this blog called the takeout and
they have a lot of stuff that i find
really fascinating about different
chains like around the country and
sometimes they'll talk about ones that
i'm like i've never been there because
we don't have it and culver's is one
that a lot of people like talk about
being like the best thing ever but it's
just kind of like just like southerners
talking about how public subs are way
better than
any of the other sub chains and i will
die on that hill because that's
absolutely true i mean we've you know
obviously subway is
passable
as food um
jimmy john's is pretty good uh i don't
think quiznos is around anymore they
were okay
um what's the other one firehouse those
are pretty good i've only eaten there a
couple of times
but public subs are
divine yeah publix they're so good yeah
if you want a sub
you just go to the [ __ ] grocery store
go to publix
go to their deli go to the deli my
favorite one is
you get like the roast beef sub on
multigrain it's that
that bread
and i always get
spinach tomatoes
banana peppers a little bit of oil and
vinegar yeah
and a little bit of cheese little bit of
mayo right no no mustard though there's
a bunch of different selections of meats
you could probably [ __ ]
you could probably ask for double meat
too there's probably all about different
things you can do well yeah you can get
whatever you want uh sly is saying he's
he was in uh on the dmz in 86. yeah i
didn't i didn't catch exactly what your
mos was i was 11 bravo it was infantry
i was uh uh my camp was uh camp greaves
up beyond [ __ ] mgm river
so i was the most forward i was at the
most forward camp the first in the 506.
there was only one
one battalion out of our regiment at
that time 506 is now back with 101st and
i think there's two more battalions now
the 506. but back in those days we were
the dmz battalion and our camp was right
next to camp warrior base where the
where our [ __ ]
we call them tourists because they just
they moved up there from from the south
and they would do little
30 days there at the [ __ ] warrior
base we lived right next to it
camp grieves
uh camp greaves is now
it was it was across a [ __ ] um mgm
river bridge
i checked all that [ __ ] out years back
man my camp is now a [ __ ]
tourist [ __ ] um museum they
can't grieve it's still there but it's
just a museum
and um they blew the bridge and
everything they got new bridges
i manned that bridge during one of the
phases
me and [ __ ] rock army troops
i got some rock army stories
[ __ ] trying to grab my ass and
[ __ ] up there [ __ ] it wasn't just me
that [ __ ] grab tally's ass [ __ ]
black dude we knew and [ __ ] tally
beat one of his ass for a [ __ ] grab
is this don't you ever [ __ ] touch a
black man's ass
[ __ ] get your [ __ ] beat up those [ __ ]
rock army dudes didn't have any [ __ ]
limits see
they they if they thought you were
[ __ ] cute or pretty they try to grab
your ass or something i don't understand
them but they were hand-holding
[ __ ] you know how they work
[ __ ] trying to hold hands all
the time
crazy [ __ ] anyway
um
that [ __ ] we had that [ __ ] bridge
totally [ __ ] rigged with c4
so at a moment's notice
if if an invasion happened we were
supposed to blow our own bridge
so they couldn't come across it so i did
that for a while
was that guard post collier
uh did patrol
and i did qrf
did [ __ ] team spirit
1991 i think it was team spirit
this was [ __ ] hell and then did the
year there and they went to the hunter
first for
first 327 recon and a recon platoon in
the inf tree did that for a while
and then i went to a live platoon after
that because uh bollowed out a [ __ ]
ranger indoctrination program for
selection
didn't pass a swim test so they said
well you can't be in a you can't be in a
in a recon platoon if you can't pass if
you're not going to get a ranger tab
it's just [ __ ] because i just did my
last like six months uh right now it was
16 months actually more like 16 at uh in
alpha company a boop
i went to uh
uh mfo mission in egypt did the sinai
mission that was fun
and uh and then got out and then ended
up doing other things later on with uh
as often i was a salesman for a while
and then i did some contracting for a
while and then just then i'm doing this
and
did farming and ranching off and on and
in the horse industry but
now i'm pretty much retired i got my va
check coming so i don't really i don't
really have to worry about it anymore
and we'll just see how it goes man
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ]
gonna happen
uh
i might i might get back into it i don't
know uh we'll see
good player dude says i had a sorry ass
birthday party at howard johnson's once
that's a blast from the past i had sorry
as one's other places i think we got him
here we got howard johnson's here they
were good last time i went i don't think
we have any anymore i mean i remember
seeing one when i was a kid on the way
back from [ __ ] uh downtown we used to
pass howard johnson's
after the falcon
coming back in the falcon yeah
well like wait no no no no no no no no
no no no no no that's not how it just
that was an ihop yeah yeah i was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i
haven't seen a howard johnson that was
little they had that orange roof
i know yeah yeah it was like a motor
like yeah yeah that's right the only
thing it was it was also a an inn wasn't
it yeah yeah and a restaurant like a
motor lodge yeah at a restaurant yeah a
long time like i said i remember we had
one in daytona and the last time i saw
that was in the [ __ ] 70s yeah or
maybe early 80s the only thing that was
good at howard johnson's was the fried
clams
yeah i remember yeah i remember liking
it and i think they were known for that
yeah yeah that was kind of like their
scene yeah their signature jitsu yeah
those cry clowns you could get a [ __ ]
huge damn pile of them fry clams uh yeah
i'll eat anything like from the ocean
pretty much gramphther says uh granthar
went to a hooters in durban south africa
once exact same greasy food and flat
bear is here oh that's nice it's a small
world after all isn't it only difference
was fruit bats were flying over the
rooftop deck
yeah that's hilarious that they have
[ __ ] hooters yes sly if you served
there in 86 how old are you you must be
late 50s huh okay what
uh murder hornet return says i hated top
gun but this trailer looks good yeah i
wasn't a big fan of the original top gun
either but uh it's you know it it looks
good also people say it's great yeah
rebecca said you haven't seen top gun
yet you have to it's wow this is great
yeah granthar says top gun seen it uh
total tom cruise vanity project well
pretty much all well they all are um
exact same plot as star wars a new hope
uh fun as hell movie okay yeah yeah some
people are saying it's warriors journey
and [ __ ] heroes hero's journey yeah i
mean i can i feel like
a lot of movies have that same yeah i
don't want to hear any of the spoilers
because
they were everybody's doing [ __ ]
spoiler reviews and they loved it and i
don't want to hear the spoils
we'll go we'll go
maybe we could go tomorrow
we'll see how we go i mean we could go
tomorrow if i'm not too hot okay
because i mean it's not like it's gonna
be super packed maybe because it's
already been playing yeah but it's
already been playing like a week or two
you see it during the day i want to see
it in the uh in the dolby theater yeah
well yeah obviously okay
like i said i still want to see that a24
movie men too because that that looks
[ __ ] up so i want to see that but i'm
sure it's probably going to be gone by
the time we get there but you know
that's i guess i'll have to wait for it
still playing the northman
that's coming to peacock is it
um like streaming i don't know how much
you're gonna have to pay to see it i'm
just gonna wait for the blue but
well yeah you should probably buy
that yeah grandpa said there actually
wasn't much homoerotic stuff in
top gun too that must have been an 80s
thing it definitely was an 80s thing and
the funny thing about it was that
i don't know i don't know how aware they
were of it i think it's like a lot more
home or erotic in
hindsight i think like during the 80s
people were kind of like aware like
maybe low-key aware of it but it wasn't
like now where everyone was like holy
[ __ ] that is like the gayest thing that
i've ever seen you know what i mean it's
i don't know
it's just like people were thinking
about it it's almost kind of like oh
that's like so macho i'm like it's it's
really not but whatever
uh you know
let's see where was i yeah linwood says
i'm retired also san antonio texas
um
[Music]
crystals oh yeah
man that brings back memories too
yeah crystals is kind of like it's sort
of like white castle in the sense that
you get these tiny little burgers and
they come in little boxes and you get
like a big sack of them
and i remember when i was a kid
you know we didn't really have a lot of
fast food options like that close to
where we lived so usually
and we didn't have like a lot of money
either so usually if we were gonna eat
out or get something out which was like
a big deal because we hardly ever did it
we would either get
uh pizza from this little mom and pop
place that was only a couple miles away
which was called pantheon who made
pretty much the best sausage and onion
pizza i've ever eaten in my life before
or since
and i don't think they're there anymore
but i haven't been back to daytona a
long time but it was like a little
mom-and-pop place or we would get
crystals like my grandpa would go and
get like a massive bag like crystals
burgers and get them
and they have a very distinctive smell
crystals do and i don't know i don't
think i've ever had white castle because
i'm not sure i don't think they have
white castle in florida
unless i'm do we have white castles here
um i kind of feel like we have crystals
which is kind of the same thing i don't
think it's the same thing it's not owned
by the same company i don't think i
thought it was i think i know i think it
it was something where it broke into two
it is the same company or it was or it
was at one point right
crystals i've had them both and crystals
is the same there's no difference that's
what i thought yeah i mean i thought it
looks
pretty much the same like i said they
come in this lot of boxes exactly and
the buns are steamed yeah and it's just
got like little like
little uh like onion pieces like little
fried onion pieces now i'm gonna do i'm
gonna i'm gonna give you i'm gonna do
exactly what slide told me to do
and give you all an education
better than anything from [ __ ]
harvard all right
the
when somebody will look at white castle
and go man that's not a real hamburger
you don't know food history
white castle was the original hamburger
they invented it jeffy yard said they're
supposed to be the world's largest white
castle in orlando is there yeah might be
i don't know i haven't seen it i don't
know where it's at maybe it's on
international drive i mean that's like
kind of the tourist area and i never go
there so i don't know the hamburger has
come now the world's largest mcdonald's
yeah is in orlando i know that the
hamburger has come very far in history
when it started it was that white castle
burger that's what they saw
and it was just yeah it was just like a
little like a little meat cracker yeah
they had to hire doctors to stand
outside there when it first opened it to
let everybody know that this is healthy
because they didn't know a ground beef
this is the very early 1900s
and they were smart they put them in
factory areas
to try to get factory workers to come in
there in mass to eat them
and in the day it was that was good
nutrition because you had meat bread and
vegetables
and the vegetables were pickles and
ketchup that was the vegetable
okay i mean technically well no i was
going to say technically ketchup's not a
vegetable because tomatoes tomato right
and technically you gotta remember
there's not refrigeration at this time
and you had the heinz company
made a huge industry
out of pickling and canning vegetables
and then having them distributed all
over
the united states in these little
general stores
and that was the vegetable supply for
america
fresh vegetables were something you only
got at fairs
you know and out of out of your own
family farm
but at the corporate
mass level it was heinz
that provided vegetables because no
refrigeration so it was pickles
and ketchup and mustard and mayonnaise
out of a jar and that was and a
mayonnaise was considered a topping but
it's like a protein because it was egg
egg whites
so
we look at those condiments and [ __ ]
well that's just something you add on to
food
back in the early 1900s that was the
food
well now technically every time i ate
every time we got crystals which we did
a lot when i was growing up because it
was one of the places that was close
um all that was on there
was the meat the onions the onions and
the pickles and the pickle and mustard
mustard there was no ketchup and there
was no mayonnaise i didn't even i would
add ketchup to ketchup right but i think
all it had on it was mustard i don't
even remember mustard being on them i
think i'm pretty sure that was just
onions and pickles it was just mustard
onion right onion pickles i'm pretty
sure that's all that was on there
because i would always add ketchup
because i'm like [ __ ] them not putting
any [ __ ] ketchup on the [ __ ] what are
you thinking and the and the the um
the white castle or crystal
bun
is the original hamburger bun which was
nothing more
than a dinner roll
yeah like a steamed dinner
yeah
and the innovation was
the innovation was is to take ground
beef
and send it through a processing thing
where they kind of pushed it through a
little machine and when it came out it
came out
in little meat
cracker patties that had holes in them
and everything to to speed up the rate
at which it would cook
and they had a special griddle that
where the meat juices would come and run
down at an angle and go into the side of
the griddle that had all the diced
onions and cooked those and then there
was another place where they could put
the buns on there so it was like a big
conveyor belt with these dudes working
and they could pump out a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ] hamburgers to feed entire
factories
so it was a well thought out
process system
to feed as many people as possible with
with the best nutrition
possible for the era
so kind of a modern marvel in a way
you know
well thought out
oracle says jenny have you seen the
series the food that built america i
don't think i have but that sounds right
up my alley yeah they look at famous
food companies histories so they talk
about heinz white castle kellogg's all
that kind of stuff
what is it on because yeah
i would totally watch that i think i've
seen it i'm fascinated by the food
history yes i find that like really
really interesting well because
everybody has to eat so food like says
so much about like the culture at large
you know what i mean i just i love that
kind of stuff murder hornet says i buy
those frozen white castle burgers still
taste good yeah i don't think i've ever
had those actually but yeah they still
said the frozen ones white castle or gut
bombs says granthars but if there's a
better hangover food please share with
the class
yeah but they're good though yeah you're
drunk you can eat all kinds of
isn't it i wonder why when you're drunk
you always want something like that i
guess it's your body's like trying to
like soak up the alcohol because like i
said when i'm drunk all i want is like
breakfast food like eggs and pancakes
and [ __ ] or
like just i want something fatty and
they do tell you it's better to eat
something fatty because it does help to
like to soak up the alcohol so you don't
feel so [ __ ] the next i says what tom
you're the man i don't know exactly what
he's talking about let's be talking
about where i was where i was oracle
says the first two seasons are on hulu
oh [ __ ] okay
i'm watching that yes i was stationed i
was stationed up on the dmz uh alpha
company of my unit
uh was stationed at liberty bell
and they were they took care of the
places where panmunjom where they did
all the peace talks so i knew those
dudes too went to basic with some of
them
i actually wasn't tall enough to get
into alpha company
if you to go to alpha company you had to
be above six feet
in that era no shorties at alpha company
because they were in a [ __ ]
they were in a in that era they were at
a in a [ __ ] arms race to see who was
taller
all right
because they're face to face with the
north koreans
so
only
south koreans like six foot tall could
be there and only americans six foot and
above could be there and they were
trying to put the tallest north koreans
they could on the other side no the a
tall north korean was [ __ ] five eight
five ten i mean those [ __ ] are small
man small they they didn't have the
nutrition
the idea was when you're standing there
prayed rest and looking over that line
is to look down on them
you know then they didn't like that so
they wanted to [ __ ] back us apart so
that way they're looking down
staying by the parade rest around those
buildings and staring across them
the mdl going through the middle
it was wild
john gore says haven't had any wendy's
in years but i remember them being the
superior burger joint for the times yeah
i always kind of liked wendy's burgers
and i liked that they had baked potatoes
yeah which the other fast food places
didn't have so you could get like a
baked potato instead of french fries
also their frosties are awesome
blair de dude says i miss arthur
treachers so do i i don't remember that
one arthur treachers actually when i
grew up in
daytona beach we had a sit-down arthur
creatures restaurant it's kind of like
well it's like it's a fish place like
fried fish but it's like i want to say
it's like long john silver's but it was
like a classier version of that it was
kind of like with british pubs
style branding
yeah so they had like these big plank
fries
and you know big pieces of fish that
were like fried in the batter and stuff
like that and i used to [ __ ] love
that place when i was a kid and so you
know uh you know sometimes when i was a
little kid like on my birthday i'd be
like i want to go to arthur creatures
last time i saw an arthur treacher
was
back in 2008
2009 in the orlando airport they did
have an arthur creatures
like a kiosk that was like split with
some other restaurant that i don't
remember what it was but i was like
super jazzed the food wasn't as good as
i remember but it was still like okay
now oracle's talk about how savage heinz
was yeah he was you know he was he was a
robber baron an oligarch but we still
got him you know they're still doing
that [ __ ] today but uh that he was like
jp morgan and all the other guys [ __ ]
carnegie but he was the food dude
um but it made sense you know what i
mean they were trying to
feed america
uh as efficiently as possible and to
bring
products as deep as as many as possible
to the deep inaccessible regions of the
united states
and it was going to take it was going to
take a robber baron slash oligarch to do
that so that's just the way the hinds
were especially in the pre-refrigeration
era huge task
so it was all going to have to be jarred
and like you said he put in glass buying
up all the damn glass bottles and [ __ ]
to get it done
he invented the heinz mr heinz invented
branding when it came to food he would
just he would have sales
back in the day you wanted to be a hind
salesman because you could just go up to
a little mom-paw store and say
look i'll tell you what
um
if you let me i will put an aisle down
this down your store and i will stock
your store
24 7 seven days a week of all these
[ __ ] products and we'll give you a
cut
and it'll be beautiful they're like yeah
yeah so they would come in and they
would build a beautiful aisle with all
this [ __ ] um uh a pr branding and all
these graphics and stuff it was just cut
above the
the uh the rest and and store owners
wanted heinz in their company in in
their little mom paw stores because they
would
build you a beautiful aisle and keep
that [ __ ] stocked and if you were that
salesman is your job to continue to go
through your route and stock that place
and everybody getting a cut
and
that was a system it was like direct
sales you know so they had guys were
direct sales in regional
so your heinz representative filling out
the paperwork trying to restock your
shelves and [ __ ] and as a store owner
you didn't have to do anything that
thing would just sit there and make
money like a vending machine so it was a
good way of doing it
heinz truck would show up and they made
themselves a [ __ ]
uh they made themselves a [ __ ]
fixture in in the american culture of
that era because you'd see trucks going
by with beautiful
heinz you know [ __ ] written on the
side it looked official and [ __ ] you
know people could trust it it came out
of a damn heinz jar
pickles
pickle [ __ ] onions and [ __ ]
broccoli and carrots and then
mayonnaise mustard ketchup relish
different kinds of relish
and it was and a good thing one good
thing about heinz is that the girls that
the people doing all the [ __ ] and the
bottling with girls
he was one of the first company to give
like really good jobs and good paying
jobs to to women
and they had little
uniforms they had to wear and it was a
pretty good
working environment for the time you
know i mean it wasn't like sweatshop
[ __ ] it was
it looked medical for the time
everything was like medical and
uh real uh
because they had so much problems such a
bad reputation with [ __ ] bad
sanitation in the food industry heinz
changed all that so everything looked
like a hospital
in the uh
when it was with heinz it kind of had a
medical
vibe to it which
good business
you know
change the food industry
dj maniac says we only had a handful of
arthur creatures here and very briefly
usually combined with another restaurant
nathan's more than likely yeah that's
what it was um i don't i don't know if
it's there anymore i've been to the
orlando airport in uh several years but
i remember the last time i ate in arthur
treacher's was back in like the mid to
late 2000s and it was arthur creatures
and yeah it was uh half that and half
nathan's as well
buddy data said we have sonic and
checkers
probably like crystal no crystals is
completely different crystals is more
like white castle
um as far as i know all they have are
those little bitty burgers and
do they have french fries i don't know
they maybe have french fries i don't
know but checkers
and sonic are more like old school like
diner
burgers and fries
type [ __ ] we used to have a checkers i
don't know if it's still there
but we used to have a checkers like in
daytona i used to like it because it was
in this big um parking lot that was near
like a bookstore that i used to go to
and you could walk up to the window it
wasn't a drive-through window it was a
walk-up they had a drive-through too but
you had they had a walk-up window and i
thought that was cool and their burgers
were pretty good their fries were pretty
good it was you know it was good and it
was kind of cheap and i think they had
chicken sandwiches too um sonic is
pretty good but i've only been there a
couple times i kind of feel like people
go to sonic more
for their like drinks don't they have
like those kind of all those like slushy
kind of drinks with all those flavors
and stuff like a lot of people are into
that seems like
but yeah it's nothing like crystal
though crystal is more like white castle
yeah it is white castle if you ask me i
don't even know yeah
i don't like what science do they have
like i they're kind of just known for
the burgers i don't even know if they
have anything other than that they might
have like some breakfast sandwiches on
the same i'm pretty sure that crystals
is
i'm pretty sure the crystals is white
castle they were the same company at one
point and uh
they're using the same strategy it's the
same product i can't tell them apart
i mean i've never eaten a white castle
so i don't know i've only had crystal
i'd have to check the i'd have to check
history on it
but if i remember correctly just off the
top of my head they were the same
company at one point and then murder
hornet says uh we have an a w and long
john silver's combo store here yeah i
think we have some of those although the
one we have here i think is half long
john silver's and half taco bell
is it not yeah remember that one like
over by the mall
i'm pretty sure that's half long john
silver's and half taco bell yeah and i
actually think i went through the drive
through there one time
and they didn't have the long john
silver's menu that day they're like no
we just we're just doing taco bell today
and i was like well [ __ ] you then once
you polish that off and i'll make you
another one
oh okay
we using up the rest of the vodka
we still got like an hour before we
gotta go anywhere
and i still gotta like eat some dinner
too yeah
uh
let's see we used to have a delivery
truck for chips called mr chips delivery
of snacks yeah we had those two i
remember those weren't they kind of like
they weren't yellow but they were kind
of like beige tan it was like tan and
black or something is that what you're
talking about i've seen those
jack-in-the-box curly fries yeah i
really like curly fries to be honest i
used to really like i don't think they
have these anymore
but back in the old days um at kfc
for a while they had those big wedge
french fries with the skin on them and
man i love those like the planks
and i don't know what kind of fries they
got at kfc now i haven't eaten a kfc and
i don't remember how long
but
yeah for a time they had those big like
flank those big plank fries with like
the skin on them and i really like those
i kind of wish that
more restaurants would make those but
they don't really have them you just
have like kind of like skinny [ __ ]
fries or sometimes that's good i don't
know
all french fries are pretty good
dj maniac says my brother and i went to
sonic a few times he completely missed
the point he'd get the order to go and
then stick up my apartment with whatever
you ordered
dude it's an atmosphere
i think i've only eaten that sonic have
i ever eaten at sonic now that i'm
thinking about it i think i might have
gone through the drive through or
whatever like one time and got a drink
from there like when i was with a friend
but i don't know we have a few of them
around here i don't think i've ever
eaten at one now that i'm thinking about
it it's possible i might have and i just
didn't remember
so
i don't know
yeah bunny daddy said we have krispy
kreme if red light is on means donuts
are hot oh yeah krispy kreme
i love krispy kreme we used to have one
where i grew up there was a krispy kreme
it might it's probably still there it
was there last time i was in daytona
that was like a little while back
it was in
not the greatest neighbor it wasn't a
terrible neighborhood but it was like an
iffy neighborhood
but it had been there since i was born
maybe before i was born it's this tiny
little krispy kreme just on the corner
of this these two big uh you know roads
and every time we drove past there
because you had to drive back try pass
there like go to the mall and like go to
the college and [ __ ] like that
and if that light was on you can [ __ ]
bet that i was like pulling into that
[ __ ] that's pulling into that
parking lot and getting one donut that's
the last one okay but i realized that
downstairs i have that
daiquiri
well that's so i don't want to drink
anymore okay just because like i said we
gotta go out later yeah yeah
but yeah if you get if you go to krispy
kreme and you when their hot donuts now
sign is on if you go in there and get
one of their you have to get like the
glazed donuts so like all their other
donuts are pretty good too but like the
only ones that are good like right out
the oven
are the just the plain glaze ones and
you eat it and it's like it's almost
kind of like um
cotton candy it just like dissolves
in your mouth it's like because it's
like really hot and really sugary and
it's really really good i'm talking
about fast food we got [ __ ]
a bigger crowd than normal just sitting
here everybody we'll see
that's what i'm saying ever well
everybody has to eat so everyone can
relate yeah everybody has opinions yeah
on what kind of food is good because
like i said it's relatable yeah i mean
most people have eaten in fast food
places but everybody eats food and
everybody's got opinions about food so
you know what i mean
yeah it was a beige metal canister
that's right yeah i remember it i
remember
the hot light
yeah man i haven't had krispy kreme in a
long time i love donuts but this cream's
good i gotta eat a whole pack of them
[ __ ] i could see you probably the
fresh ones just saying i'm not proud of
that but i'm sure they don't weigh
anything there's not much mass there
that's what i mean
i mean the glazed ones yeah yeah
maybe one day then maybe that's what i'd
do if i was on death row i'm just like
bringing me a dozen those [ __ ] hot
krispy kremes i'm just gonna sit there
and eat every [ __ ] one although
yeah
it's been a long time since i've done it
yeah i could go to dunkin donuts [ __ ]
pull in there and get a cup of coffee
and [ __ ] eat probably half a dozen
donuts the [ __ ] fancy has donuts with
all the [ __ ]
i could too like i said i'm not proud of
that let me get a cherry doughnut with
the cherry cream frosting on the top
with the sprinkles and
the [ __ ] little kids will eat i'll eat
the [ __ ] out of those i will say i'm not
i'll eat the [ __ ] i'll eat the [ __ ] i
don't know i'm not proud
eclairs i haven't had a donut in forever
because i'm always kind of like every
now and then like sometimes i'll be
working in the morning i'm like god i
wish i really had i wish i had a
doughnut
but i'm too one i'm too lazy to like go
drive i don't even know where you can
get a doughnut around here yeah but um i
mean other than the grocery store i
don't know if there's i don't i'm sure
there's like a dunkin donuts or
something around here but i don't know
where it is yeah so i'm like i'm too
lazy to go get it and i was like no i
better not because i feel like if i get
one donut
then i'm gonna get a bunch of donuts i'm
gonna get i'm gonna get like six or
twelve of them and i'm gonna eat every
[ __ ] one i'm [ __ ] bad i mean
i'll eat the boston creams the [ __ ]
uh the [ __ ] eclairs [ __ ] with the
the [ __ ] custard and [ __ ] and then
turn right around and eat a blueberry
doughnut with cherry frosting on it just
like [ __ ] like a little kid would eat
i'd eat that too i'll just like that now
i will say i'm not strawberry doughnut
as far as donuts go and like i'm i'm not
hating because all donuts are good
all donuts are good donuts okay i'm not
gonna turn down any donut i don't care
what it is but i do have some kind of
like favorite ones i'm not a huge fan of
the ones with fruit in the middle
although i do like the ones that are
like apple in the middle i do like the
apple fritter type ones yeah if i'm
gonna get one i really like the boston
creams yeah i really like dunkin donuts
used to i don't know if they still do
but they used to make one that was like
a powdered donut that had like a white
buttercream what about maple bars
remember those maple bars maple those
are good
crawlers are good
um like i said pretty much all of them
old school [ __ ] maple bar yeah oliver i
typical maple anything is like pretty
delicious but i'm not even big bacon on
it i'm not a big fan of ones that have
fruit in the middle but i'll eat them
i'm not picky you know what i'm saying
and i'm not a huge fan of like the
chocolate donuts i don't mind if they
have like chocolate icing on them
but you know the ones that are like all
chocolate like chocolate cake donuts
yeah those are good too um they're okay
but that's not my favorite like i would
pick something else before i would pick
that you know what i'm saying
but man now i want donuts yeah no you're
[ __ ] me up
that's some of our british listeners but
like hold on what's this [ __ ] is it
jelly donut because for them jelly means
jello it's not does not have jell-o god
don't put jell-o inside no that's you'd
ruin it and it's jam
it's a [ __ ] big puffy
white doughnut with
with glaze
inside of it with like usually like
raspberry jam in the middle usually it's
raspberry oh
god hell yes with [ __ ]
w
with icing sugar powdered sugar on the
outside oh man
real good oracle says i miss donuts
stupid diabetes right it's like god damn
it and i'm just kind of like like i said
i don't have diabetes that i know of but
i just feel like i really really want
one once sometimes but i'm just kind of
like man if i if i get off my ass and go
all the way to get donuts then i'm not
just going to get one donut when i get i
mean maybe if i was just like walking
around somewhere and saw a donut place
and it was like breakfast time or
whatever then i would just go in there
and get one but if i'm going to drive
and go get them then yeah i'm going to
get like yeah i said today is national
donut day so we can talk about yeah
that's right yeah somebody mentioned
that earlier maybe that's what yeah we
we just like just subconsciously like
remember that talking about apple
fritters and all that [ __ ] apple
fritters are so good yeah
now one thing i will say is when i was
in the uk
my ex-husband's grandma one time when i
was over visiting her
she made a whole bunch of like apple
fritters from scratch
and holy [ __ ] those were so good oh my
god they were delicious
man apple fritters yeah good yeah
rebecca said i'm a cinnamon sugar donut
person yeah those are good too i mean
cinnamon sugar anything i've honestly i
really like uh just like cinnamon sugar
toast i remember being a little kid with
mom taking me to dunkin donuts or
winchell's i remember i think it might
have been duncan or winslow
and they had the damn
halloween donuts remember with the
orange frosting yeah
i like their seasonal donuts at dunkin
donuts yeah it's cool to like go with
well i like halloween everything
because as soon as they start putting
halloween [ __ ] out or like fall [ __ ] out
like it always just makes me really
happy even though it's still hot here
but like i'll go in the store and be
like yay like summer's almost over
because i hate summer yeah so
and that was one of the things you'd go
in dunkin donuts and like all the donuts
would be like we got like you know green
witchy icing on it and like orange icing
on there and it's like that was like mr
eddie says i've always wondered why
apple has a monopoly on the fritter
medium yeah right it doesn't you could
you could do whatever you wanted it's
just uh that's a popular one that just
seems like the most popular yeah and
apples are cheap
you know what i mean but you could
easily make a berry one like a like a
blackberry or raspberry fritter you
could do all that you just want to use
when you're talking about mass marketing
you're talking about you have to serve
the entire united states okay with these
companies that's a [ __ ] huge market
so it has to be dumbed down quite a bit
and apple
orange there's your two [ __ ] fruits
those are just everywhere banana
okay
and banana wouldn't make a fritter
orange would make a fritter so you're
left with apple
chocolate
like chocolate chips that would make a
fritter
if you want something like berries
blueberry
would be a good one because cherry it
would hold together cherry would hold
together i mean cherry anything
raspberry and blackberry would hold
together
uh in that process but that would be
specialty stuff you'd have to go to a
[ __ ] mom pop
doughnut place and there's not many of
those so that means you got to make it
yourself but if you made it yourself
it'd be great a strawberry is too
uh fragile
okay when it couldn't survive the
process once you cut it up and then it
wouldn't be very impressive or tasty
if you have strawberries you might as
well turn that into a jab and use that
as a filling in in a
in a [ __ ] powdered doughnut
and we have a jelly doughnut really what
it is is it's a beignet it's a beignet
that's been stuffed with [ __ ] with fruit
filling
so
there's limitations as to what fruit you
can use for something like like a like a
fritter because it's just kind of mixed
in there at random and exposed to the
[ __ ] deep frying process
see
so it's got to be something that has a
skin on it that holds together and being
small enough to where you can take a
bite
now an apple doesn't have a skin on it
but it's okay it can be cubed and it's
strong enough to where it won't
disintegrate in the frying process
so all that shit's got to be part of the
factor another thing that would be good
be like [ __ ]
cubed up pieces of [ __ ] carrot like
carrot cake if it was [ __ ] seasoned
right if it was candied carrot that's
and a carrot cake doughnut a carrot cake
doughnut will work [ __ ] right it
would uh i wonder if anybody's made that
i mean i'm sure somebody has pulled it
out of my ass i mean i'm sure like i've
had carrot cake cupcakes obviously yeah
but like at cupcake shops yeah but i
don't think i've ever seen a carrot cake
doughnut i'm sure somebody's made that
because you can make cake doughnuts you
could dice up a carrot and [ __ ] candy
it okay in a [ __ ]
in in sugar
and put that in a fritter and cook it
but make the fritter like carrot cake
when it makes a thing with pieces of
carrot in it that'd be good
i'd have to figure it out you'd have a
lot of errors it would take several
tries
until you found the right i'd be very
surprised if had somebody hadn't made
one little baby carrots you know little
baby carrots yes because that's the
consistency kind of like an apple
um
what else would work
slides talking about lemon doughnuts and
i was like oh yeah that's that's another
one that that dunkin donuts have that i
like they do like the powdered sugar
doughnuts but it has like lemon curd
yeah inside those are also very good
because i like lemon anything now in the
south we had a cake my grandmother and
this goes back to great grandparents and
everything
i'm sure that's also probably in
soul food it's probably up north too it
was these lemon butt cakes and it's just
around like a big giant round it's got a
hole in the middle pretty sure we've put
that in the cookbook it's in the
cookbook with lemon icing on it and it's
so [ __ ] just like an angel food cake
and that is that right there is a
mississippi donut that's a southern
donut you just get a slice of that it's
a real moist heavy cake
with lemon icing on it and that's just
good as [ __ ] let's slide did your family
make those i don't know if they made
those lemon bundt cakes damn
damn they were good
i'm a big fan of lemon cake yeah
probably that's probably in soul food
too
i mean and lemon cake is good i'm trying
to think of like all they were easy to
make and they were [ __ ] delicious
like all the cakes that i liked when i
was a kid lemon cake probably up there i
think you know i know this is weird but
like one of my favorite things what i
would usually ask for for my birthday
when i was a little kid for my mom to
make was marble cake which was like a
marbled like vanilla and chocolate yeah
together
i'm gonna get that you know what i don't
have a bundt pan i'm gonna get a bundt
cake pan i'm gonna make that okay i'm
gonna make that
i haven't made that since i [ __ ]
lived in this in mississippi but i'm
gonna make that oracle says tom you know
the ultimate southern dessert is
divinity oh my god me and mom me and my
mom made that a couple times ambrosia
okay another one would be although they
have that in the midwest too what about
cocoons
yeah cocoons they look like little
[ __ ]
they look like little cocoons all right
they're they're they're uh
they're uh they're made out of [ __ ]
pecans and it's kind of a [ __ ]
cookie
and they're covered in
powdered sugar and they're real real
buttery butter cocoons that's the one
and i put that in the in the cookbook i
don't think so yeah
that's a that's an advanced one
cocoons burner horn it says mexicans put
lemon on everything so yeah i'm a fan of
that i'm a fan of that i love lemon well
lemon adds zest to anything it's good
it'll make any any well it's a flavor
it's a flavor enhancer it'll make any
fruit taste more intense
it'll make strawberry taste more like
strawberry uh lemon is great on any meat
it's uh it's good in anything it's it's
it's like the msg of the central and
south america and then it's talking
about lemon meringue oh yeah yeah yeah i
love lemon wine pie and kela i i like
lemon meringue pie better than key lime
pie key lime pie is good too but i like
lemon meringue better like i said a
lemon anything like lemon dessert
anything yeah i'm all about that good
now said they didn't have the lemon butt
cake that they they use in his family
lemon meringue cake yeah okay i don't
know that one
i can imagine is it the cake or the pie
well i don't know lemon meringue cake he
says it's lemon meringue cake right
yeah because i mean i made lemon
meringue pie i had to look that one up
but maybe and yeah lemon bars oh yeah my
grandma made lemon bars yeah that's a
southern thing like a little bit of like
powdered sugar on the top
lemon bars is kind of like a smaller
faster version of [ __ ] key lime pie
yeah
but it's more like a candy bar
but not really
more like a lemon more like a lemon uh
the key lime pie another thing that we
put in the cookbook that my grandma used
to make all the time was gooey butter
cake yeah yeah now i've also heard it
called ooey gooey butter cake
um
but that [ __ ]
man
we used to like
me and my cousins used to like nag her
to make it because she would always be
oh it's so hard to make them all it's
not really but she would say that
because she didn't she didn't want to
make it um so we would try to get her to
make it she always made it for christmas
but a lot of times we try to get her to
make it for thanksgiving too because it
was so good but it was it's so rich that
you could really only eat
i mean even a little chubby kid like me
could only eat like one piece
that's a lemon
cake that looks good oh my god that
looks really good
okay
i want to eat that right now yeah i can
just stuff that whole thing right in my
face
is it is it focusing no it's not
that's lemon meringue cake
okay well
let's see if i can get an internal shot
i mean i feel like
i've watched a lot of those uh you know
baking competition [ __ ] oh my god that
looks amazing yeah it does look good
i've like watched all those baking
competition shows and stuff like that i
mean cake technology has come a long way
since the old days
they make all kinds of [ __ ] nowadays
and
i'm all about it i'm you know i love
that kind of [ __ ] i just i don't eat it
that much because
i can't you know what i mean i'll give
i'll get fat or fatter so it's just kind
of like you know what i mean um but i
i've been a big like dessert [ __ ] my
whole life but i just really have to
stay away from it because if i eat it
all the time i'll get used to it and i'm
just kind of like oh i'll want it every
day so i can't
that
is cocoons
and then in front of it it's got it open
opened up and broken up right there so
you can see what's inside
it's a
cookie
it's it's a pecan cookie kind of like a
pecan sandy it almost looks like a like
an italian wedding cookie yeah
a little bit i never had this
which has powdered sugar on the outside
it's like a pecan it's like a pecan
sandy
covered in powdered sugar yeah shaped
kind of like ain't nothing wrong with
that yeah i love pecan sand yes
those are keebler's mixes right kiwis
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah i love those
yeah i love those my favorite cookies
growing up were pecan sandies and lorna
dunes yeah which are shortbread in case
you didn't know
um
murder hornet says in mexico they sell
elote am i pronouncing that right which
is corn on the cob smeared with mayo
sprinkled with chili powder and cheese
that would work sounds gross but it is
that does not sound good
that sounds awesome yeah yeah actually
that sounds really good it doesn't sound
gross in the slightest yeah uh fried
corn in the cob i have had that that's
like yeah that's really really good
really good
um the norse nut says uh have you
watched that horrible is it cake show on
netflix i've been very uh i've heard
about it and i'm kind of like i watched
the trailer and i'm kind of like that i
love all the cake shows like where they
like cake wars and all that kind of
stuff where they make cakes with like
themes and stuff i love that [ __ ]
and so i was kind of like man that looks
like something i would watch but the
trailer looked like it would probably
just like annoy the [ __ ] out of me so i
haven't watched it yet
but
i probably will at some point because
that
anything to do with cake i'm just like
fascinated with it so i don't know why
but uh oracle says i have a great lemon
zest thyme chicken recipe yeah see lemon
is good on any anything like that
lemon curd and sweet pastry cups also
good also good yeah lemon curd's good in
anything like i said they put it in the
middle of donuts i'll eat that
lemon's really good that's kind of like
an exception to the rule i don't know i
don't think it's a rule that i have but
donuts pastry stuff like that i usually
prefer
and it's the same with ice cream
if it's a dessert i usually prefer stuff
that's like not fruit flavored i usually
like chocolate or nuts or cinnamon or
hazelnut or whatever it is
but i do like apple stuff i do like
lemon stuff and i do like cherry stuff
so
anything to do with those three other
than that like other things like peaches
berries stuff like that it's on a
case-by-case basis because a lot of
times i don't really i'll eat it but
it's like not my favorite i will say
though
okay one thing i will say i'm not a big
fan of mangoes
again i'll eat them but it's not my
favorite they taste a little perfumey to
me
however
we have an indian restaurant here in uh
in central florida it's it's in lake
mary called memories of india and they
make their own mango ice cream and that
[ __ ] is
delicious
it is so [ __ ] good i don't even like
mangoes all that much but that [ __ ] is
so [ __ ] good i don't know what they
do to it like to make the mangoes not
taste like perfume but it's just like
it's so like creamy and rich oh it's
fantastic it's really really good and
they make it in-house too really really
good and that's pretty much they only
have two desserts there it's either rice
pudding or mango ice cream so i always
get the mango they just give you like a
little bowl of like a little frozen bowl
yeah and it's like man that's good not
even like i said i don't even like
mangoes yeah she doesn't like rice
pudding so i i [ __ ] make my i make
rice pudding i got so much [ __ ] rice
here well see that's okay because if you
make dessert and you make something that
i'm not super because
well because the thing about it is like
i feel like i can't eat a lot and i
can't eat a lot of desserts
so if i'm gonna eat a dessert it better
be something
really really good that i really really
want so if it's just something that i'm
not all that enthused about then it's
like easy for me to get them that i
found a [ __ ] easy easy way to make
rice indian rice pudding
first thing you do is you take a bun you
make a bunch of rice and i use the
cheapest rice i can get and that's uh
[ __ ] sam's club rice get that [ __ ]
[ __ ] 25 pound bags man
back in the day it was like a nothing
did you cook that rice two cups of it
then you take a frying pan
take about a half a cup of butter half a
stick of butter excuse me put it in
there and [ __ ]
melt it
throw a [ __ ] big ol
long [ __ ] um cinnamon stick in it
three cloves
and some cardamon pods
there's indian spices and sit there and
just kind of lightly fry them spices
until that
till that butter gets dark
take the rice
throw the [ __ ] spiced butter on it
throw the spices away if you want
and then put uh
milk in it powdered milk
i use powdered milk neato
because it's easier to control the
the thickness
it's probably in two cups of rice
probably about a cup of milk maybe half
a cup but you want it thick like cream
and some vanilla and just mix it just
too thick add a little bit of water let
it sit overnight come back the next day
put that into a tall glass like [ __ ]
like a ice like like like a wine got
like a wine glass for for like a for
like a sunday or something you know like
an ice cream sundae put it in there
let it chill in the refrigerator take it
out whipped cream on it sprinkle a
little bit of damn
powdered
cinnamon on the [ __ ]
top of the
top of the whipped cream for garnish and
eat that oh man that's just so good
it tastes like a spicy
kind of an intim spicy [ __ ]
creamy
rice pudding
let's see who's gonna
myrna hornet said that he had a filipino
girlfriend that got him some corn ice
cream it was it was good yeah they had
corn they have green corn ice cream in
brazil it's really good that would
probably be good yeah i mean corn is
kind of sweet yeah that would work they
sweeten it even more yeah but it's green
corn
emilio verde [ __ ] green corn
um yeah that's good you wouldn't know it
doesn't taste like corn it just
i mean even if it did that's
not i wouldn't be mad about it it tasted
more like pistachio ice cream kind of
again nothing wrong with that yeah yeah
absolutely whitney graham says y'all
should uh start a cooking special here
on youtube making me hungry over here
well we did we had that for a while i
mean
we did like a few episodes like instead
of matinee shows but we just i don't
know yeah remember remember we got a
cookbook
yeah so
put it on the cookbook cook was funny
because we ended up like talking about
[ __ ] i dictated i dictated the
cookbook [ __ ] directly to jen and
[ __ ] yeah i just recorded him talking
and then i just kind of like typed out
what he said yeah i talk all kinds of
[ __ ] in the cookbook
it was funny though john gore says devil
dogs were the bomb as a kid they still
got those did they still have devil dogs
i remember those that weren't there
because kind of like they were about
that long and they were chocolate with
like kind of white yeah uh like stuff
inside like white icing or
something i got fool's gold in the in
the in the uh
in the in the cookbook which is that was
elvis's favorite [ __ ]
sandwich which is a [ __ ] low french
bread an entire [ __ ] an entire
jar of [ __ ] peanut butter an entire
jar of grape jam
and bacon
i don't think a [ __ ] toasted [ __ ]
french bread that's what it does as one
does and it it it was called fool's gold
[Laughter]
now do i expect you to eat that no
no please don't eat it do not eat that
that was just i mean you can i mean live
your life but we're not telling we're
not advising it
i included that
to let you know if i can you know that
that's what elvis said but uh
if you try to make fool's gold don't
don't make it in that portions okay well
i mean you could make it and then like
just have a little bit every time just
make a normal peanut butter toasted
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and put
a couple slices of bacon on it yeah i
mean that's not hard you don't have to
make a whole like loaf out of the [ __ ]
right that's just like flexing at that
point
yeah this was flexing
[Laughter]
why am i doing this because i can yeah
it was like that yeah i kind of feel
that yeah
holy [ __ ] all right so oh [ __ ] it's 8
20.
so it's about time we should probably
get this okay and i'm gonna
i'll heat up some food all right i'll
see you guys later because we need to
like have some food i need to put on the
rest of my outfit it's mostly done yeah
but i put on the brush my outfit and
we're gonna head out this evening
and do some dancing and [ __ ] like that
so hopefully you guys had a good time
hanging out with us talking about food
like we usually do uh we'll be back on
sunday probably talking about movie but
i don't know which one we're gonna talk
about whatever we end up watching
tomorrow night will probably be what
we're gonna talk about um like i said i
kind of wanted to finish up i don't know
i'll figure it out i i kind of started i
started uh season four with stranger
things i watched the first four episodes
so i still got three left i think but i
don't know we probably won't talk about
that because tom doesn't give a [ __ ]
about it but we'll talk about a movie on
sunday so thank you everybody for
dropping by this evening thanks for
super chats and you guys have a good
weekend and we will see you on sunday
afternoon
bye